[music]
at
but
[music]
on the final third day rapido on
tournament grant h chair infusion leader
tournament in the forest continued to demonstrate
the highest class and achieved an impressive
separation from the pursuers
it's too early to relax he says everything
anything can happen in blitz
indeed a group of persecutors in
led with lemon to the Armenians and your maxim
kilogram will do everything possible to
catch up with the leaders waiting for you 18
thrilling tours of the lightning game in
performed by the world's best grandmasters
the fourth day of the tournament starts right
now
[music]
good afternoon dear friends
it's time for our next show
Please note that we are monitoring developments.
in the city of Lebanon where the first
tournament first stage syria crane hour tour
2018 for you comment
grandmaster yaroslav is not my god
colleague I am Evgeny Miroshnichenko
and let the strongest compete for you
absolutely grandmaster of the planet for
with the exception of the unfortunate world champion
Magnus Carson and as it was said
after after
rapido before after three days of rapid chess
we have an American grandmaster in the lead
you forests and here are interesting parallels
because it's exactly the same
result yes here we are admiring and on
actually exactly the same
he showed the result last year but
then something went wrong
Let us remind you that 18 rounds of blitz are ahead of us
today 9 tomorrow 9 date generally possible
a total change of scenery, but he already
there is a large margin i.e. three points off
nearest to nearest pursue
investigators are of course very serious
advantage but let's not forget that
here we have at the tournament
real blitz experts
there is also Hikaru Nakamura who has
he is absolutely four points away from you whether soda
and even maybe there from the low low
start Grischuk yes, that is, he needs
of course make up for 6 points which is very and
very difficult, but we know that Alexander
grischuk can fight sergey karyakin
can fight you in general we'll see
yes, ten minutes left before the start
parties in lebanon yes good morning to those who
looks groove and united states of america
so what can we see
probably for the upcoming pairs of the first
tour, and here it is necessary to say a little about
format that unfortunately the tables are so
fast up to 5 minutes plus 3 seconds per move
but we won't be able to show all the games then
we will try to concentrate
then the main couple of the tour I think that for
this for this tour it will be a party
thoughts soda that's how u are forever confident
runs the distance well and you know that
great choice because you have a face
will play black with lemon aronian yes
here are 800 they are just wait
we don't have it we have it seems to me here
a small error in the draw at the very
actually this is how i see yes you
from the forest still plays black with ryan
it shows us yes here she is
the right one is the right foal
correct draw small no moisture
moment because here, judging by wparam
that I see judging by the couples that I
I see on electronic boards we live like
us a little different
well let's go now let's go now
parties will start we then then
let's figure it out so those who we actually have
who plays before grandmasters understand that
plays with us all the same
back to a little
to rapid remember what happened to us
really passed under the sign in if
sleep completely rapido just total
domination that surprised us here
yaroslav particular is very strange
game yes here is vichy anand and very confident
game of fabiano caruana who alternated
beautiful
really beautiful so logical
Party absolutely well I would say
unemployed defeats such can
maybe a little tired after all
this one through the tournament on that one plays here
almost continuously and probably expected
saved came yes yes yes probably still yes
because well
such a fantastic result chain
in one after another and now somewhere somewhere already
Fabian is probably going down
absolutely normal the main thing is on the rise
now approach the decisive start of the year
to the ocean it's understandable it will be powerful
kingdom is because we see
players are going to graze slowly
fit
well, blitz, as we said, even such
that's five plus three a little bit in length and
control than what we used to before
usually play 3 minutes + 2 seconds per
move even five plus three it's all the same it
it's more important the speed of the reaction before
intuition is important by the way strange and
adding time three seconds i something
I can't even remember what you are
someday in life such a tournament
2 somewhere play play give three seconds
many denunciations can be behind the times
and this but such a long, long blitz
that is, we will have the beginning of each tour
half an hour before after the start, that is, 2
at 2:00 CET
time they start the first round lasts
respectively in 2 32 and so on and so
then 9 games will be played today
well let's see what to expect let me remind you
what do we have here and mamedyarov and do not need
discount the same blitz it
can show himself yes maxim entered
logrov is by the way a very strong blitz plus
nakida and many more tours
18 game if if blitz was also 9
parties then you could actually about
final yes then it would be the end
win back three points difference in 9 rounds
actually impossible 217 still 88
eye the whole distance and that's how we
spoke in if was in the lead last year
he had two points clear of
nearest pursuer such a maxim
midges of logres, but from Magnus Carson
he had three points, that is, the situation
can be said to be identical. which we have
now the tournament, well, how are you all probably
know in a tournament in lebanon and a year ago
2017 won just magnus
carlsson who then you know
bullet train walked through
this blitz tournament didn’t beat it there
I remember how many but a lot of points and
overtook the whole forest about if scored in a blitz
tournament eight and a half out of 18 minus
one with not particularly fast played up to one
game more than won, let's see
will he succeed this year that is me so
I will say that here is the result + 1 if it is
dials say nine and a half then
almost certainly almost certainly
will be the first but by the way the overall standings
maybe not even sure about it or
maybe someone then maybe someone straight someone
could just break could always
zelmer then in principle it happens yes
so that somehow stand up nogel from
which you need added there the ball lies down
on the
can or how is it all now
some parallels with football well
maybe because the world cup started
tasks on he look at the format of the tournament
and what seems to be some slight delay
yes, because in 3 minutes there are minutes left
3 remain before the start players are not seated yet
so once again we are reminded of a format
tournament
rapid we have already run out of rapid let me remind you
25 minutes plus 10 seconds played and
where does such a big gap come from
your face with cotton shows here
explanation in the rapid tournament in the tournament
in rapid chess was awarded twice
more points
accordingly everything was possible
score 18 points in out of the woods scored 14
very impressive result
talk blitz regular scoring system
time control points five minutes plus 3
seconds per move 9 rounds today 9 rounds
tomorrow, yes, and looking ahead, I will say
keep reminding me of this throughout the day.
tour starts two hours early tomorrow
that is please don't miss us on
slate will start two hours early
let's look at the tournament
tournament position before the start of the blitz
Yes, once again I will give us, I can show
I hope they can show
happening there rapide
we have it where the result is written
result of the last round fast
chess yes and here is the total number of points
14 points you forest 11 and maxims
a kilogram or a won early you need these
coming pursuers in out of the woods
three points behind him by 10 points
Sergey Karyakin has Hikaru Nakamura too
dangerous slabs 49
ears feed media novel sole
participant who scored 50 percent
shakhriyar do 8 alexander grischuk and this
fabiano caruana who, well, in general,
just got together on the last day and
of course lost such a sad game
Levon Aronian but won two victories
including over sergey karyakin we
principal rival in the very
the end of the standings with us
they are weights and vichy anand, well, let's see
may be able to im like tables
change the fate of the tournament show
us anisha vs hikaru nakamura btw
points are awarded points are awarded for all
places that is, it makes sense to fight then
is in the overall standings, that is, we have everything
places get some points and there are
it makes sense to fight even if the top three is especially
don't pretend so once again here that's how I am
and how i talk like it's confusion
the draw looks like a small arose
fabiano caruana vs vichy ananda
plays da da caruana anand i try
just to understand what we have there for
par this yes here here on this small
a little confusion arose, it seems I don't
I don’t see yes so in from the forest with Sergey
karyakin them home media will smash sergey
karjakin im crane anand finally logra u
I baptize
kettlebell nakamura
so something something something here you know
I have something I don't know how we are now
we will follow this because here
something tangled up with parties ladies we
we see everything perfectly on the camera, but
some problem with electronic boards
it seems because I don't see this tour
well something incredible is happening and so
send logrov grischuk
I see we have a poke to the logger tower
where is this replacement chko
it works but now we will try
sort out
but if if we fail but
legion and gnaws for have to watch with
camera to camera will have to look from
cameras then because something is here
once again, let's say we play
mamedyarov aronyan and here and here here
my electronic boards something here
shows that ryan plays his woods
which of course we see from the camera what it is
wrong yes from the camera we see what it is
Wrong need to start the party
the party starts here is the maxim let's go
logrov vs grischuk and so what do we have there
italian went before elephant c4 sun 523
quite quite calm and development
till
someone switches us, but that's what
us here there it switches us to not
steps li and hikaru nakamura so what is it
in general, look which one is on f5
this is some kind of video and this is water
probably just Berlin
flags one yes over there play conner 4 well
such a calm development of events
calmly and developments but as we
said wot blitz
that's how much we swore yes a little
so on the chess players he calmly and began and
boring to watch in fast it happens and
very quickly there are such calm couples
greenhouses but does not actually happen taxied
there will always be a moment for
exacerbations when there are short so
short control when closer to note in
in any case, they will have time to put on, as
it says will have time to call along that is
even the best the strongest
grandmasters still allow
some mistakes of course it is desirable if
they would show us when it's a little hard
the line does not work yes so we have there
sergey karyakin plays his own again
beloved indian defense seems to be against
if soda 5 plays your favorite nova
indian defense vs if sleep well
let's see, let's see karjakin of course
specialist nova indians
it’s not clear that the pawn, by the way, according to me
again doing on there again he played yeah
or not, the dear ones would go themselves 5
go to pdn white go b5
but by the way karjakina
feared blitz such one of the best
karyakin we know that one of the best
blitz about the raw planet and here it is finally
here thanks to our thanks to our colleagues
we manage to show the party yes everything everything
we figured everything out fine and now
finally we can switch to view from
board
this is really very interesting
something's going on let's see what then
where did we duna go sos karyakin we
let's go right yes probably yes on
the most-most let's go ran a little
well slowed down a bit the game and
really we have time here
it will also be noted that in blitz often
even the electronic board can not cope with
players speed up so fast
hands flash and moves are made before that
it happens that even the move on the electronic
board is played with a delay and so
not quite guessing was the defense of him
savicha played out but turned into such a nova
Indian so-called building here
on all b6 not a bishop put on would be 7 but
everything is very simple classification and up to
the elephant is displayed on b7 this is the new indian
based on same self is old
the service will eat a short castling of the water and 8
here the whole fight looks like fired up 4 will
be conducted, but by the way, in a similar position
the data knows that there is a plan for where the whites are
horses go and 5 in 4 layers do it later
stay yes yes this is it
really but here kuni 5 yet
it is impossible for us to retell these moments in advance
need to try yes pro btw instead of off
3.5 to answer f4 aslana this move
try then moved to 44 and then
somehow queen f3 to the end punitive
attack on the kingside yes that's something
similar to true Queen's Gambit
made back in 1900 Gorin which
came up with the idea of ​​betting k on the knight on e5 and
back him up with a pawn in the chat
it's amazing when no one
thought of it.
today it seems so start now
Slavs absolutely obvious thing yes well
let's see what's next
happened to her four played karyakin
quickly here the exchange is enough
interesting followed you look scrapped
went for 3 queens 7 flowerbed d6 and karjakin
beats a pawn
good yo in need of course decision
that is, spoiled all the pawns covered
true field and 5 hid line c before but if
well, it really looks a bit
suspicious now positions on the board well
let's say that dynamically black has everything
not bad unique 400 it
but here is the static before structure available
white leaves much to be desired and bold
here they can twist, but f2 is important here
f3 if f2 f3 succeeds somehow
hold without much loss until you smoke out
called a horse and 4 that's when that
white will play with pleasure by the way
they already exchanged la digue
that's what's happening now there and now
with the game will get better 2 looks like the owner 2
or not, but he took it on c7, that's what he took
queen ic2 played on c7
now he thinks, well, if here and decided queens
don't change that's more than more than more shapes
white will change the theme them will be better then
there is only to already yes that is an attempt
go right here at school, well, at least
you know there is still such a cladding
saying amateur that the more i am
I will change the less I winter very much
right, by the way, there is such a thing
there is a white want to change this filter
blue fire h2 played just right
getting ready its about getting ready 3 less than 5
but you have to leave 2 somehow very
pretentiously look at all this window
that white whites might not care
maybe they will put him on f3 anyway
then you can even put the knight on f1
something in ukraine at 4 and we will start there
you know, kunaev 4 here f2 f3 and where
then the king and doubled h-44 let's start rolling
Well, here's to the unpromising president
played kuni fadin played yes there go
retreats to e6 f3 d6 plays Koryaks nothing
doesn't invite even 6 such move beat
me to the house, unless of course you didn’t take me like that
could be considered and taken on the same 6
there you won't do anything not so stupid at all
stupid three pawns to take on the same 6 here
look this moment is already lost but here
it’s easy for everyone to take on the same 6 on the line
take on 6 i.e. three bishop pawns
obtuse to put it mildly given would eat a
then white starts to the same g4 us
horses victims same 5 wonder little by little la
such a wait and by the way you can even there
penkin crossing for the whites we need
not bad but in general played that
played king and v2 queens eat same 2 same 3
so calm enough acts thoughts
own in this manner and he nailed
it's unbelievable towers human
the number of rapido points, that is, not particularly
went to some such aggravation gift
I tried to play calmly, but by the way I
it seems he will have a bit of a blitz
change strategy
austria up a little spicy play
because it's just hard
take advantage of all these opponents' mistakes
for my time small nuances small small
I don't think you can see the details anymore
he soon to what there is something interesting here
waiting for now structure changes then
there are not four pairs of silk, yes that
there is a take so I understand that f and then
the knight on e3 would have come up with a find neer 4
recedes karjakina we are all something
clings to the ropes so gradually everything
quite passively on and on
rollbacks known killed them problem well
how the problem is this is already a problem
rich hand on the background to attach the end
f12 now because c3
all tracer selling by the river would be one concert
refers to do
suck again
time is going to take up this horse
similar to the queen b 1 and you know you can
bring a knight a queen then another bishop
you can translate from 1-4 times
attack the pawn d5 and another question can
does black defend four times to 7
returns to that knight c3 where by the way
if black there will try a horse on with that
somehow translate the end
and here Sergey himself voluntarily
she returns 6 so stop and here where
sometime no not squeezed out to take it
6 but here in the gap black takes on
f4 in between is taken away on f4 already
a little bit wrong, well, it's white, I get two
pawns but probably you are unlikely to be near
pretend to be bandaged in this variant
so you can just play the end of 32
but still 2 by 2 so far play the end of 32
on occasion don't mind one one pair
exchange horses so what if you
planets a y takes on and 6 maybe this
same idea such not 2 next move
takes on a turtle saw her 6 don't give horses
barely
well, queen h3 is not allowed here
somehow throw the creator of the world not well
and there probably the song c7 comes in like this
olya protection correctly collect the bones there
everything just starts to fall apart
such one terribly unpleasant on green
karjakin find out played out you can say
sergey finished the game because you are now
I'll have to do something but I don't know what will come on
queen b7 must defend this mace before or
queen to queen b7
horses in seven somewhere and the icon at 4
and that's the sacrifice on the same 6 now
the sword of Damocles hangs all the time yes then
eat white all the time want that is when
with the first careless movement
careless movement immediately white
pick up our 6 get off especially
if three pawns manage to get uh huh
then it will be hard for black coaches, well
just like that presses in from the woods
sergey karyakin's queen b7 was played by a knight
went to f4 now korolev 8 starts
some attempt to crawl away by the way
I wonder how fandi works, well, what's the move
flash found found h3 yes very us
one of our 3d
by the way, bastard, if there is a queen
seven you can even the sun 8 feel this
show eyes but say some
king and 8 here do zdes but our 3 and
here he is flanges 8 some entries
start yes, in general, incredibly not
you will accept him differently even the king himself and 8
played before bedtime h3 queens have seven on
moreover, we know that Karjakin is
everything is well protected, but I'm afraid that
hard to describe does does
eight played such things in the face of you she
true king d 8
this is how sergey decided the line from the field
legnica invasion protect the king
I'm off and it's time to start
affect that snag for 50 seconds
left and as we know in an unpleasant
positions each move is given before given with
difficulty discovered queens 80 and the same
disgusting and for blacks to completely
there is no here but i don't know
a constructive plan is simply
stand by the way he probably hope
build some fortress white
so immediately do not understand how a breakthrough whole
while it is not clear how to break through yes then
there may actually be not so
just yes maybe you can some
moment already 4 it seems to me but
then about yes you can and beat icon 4 in
some point then so i just
later so not so everything is just edge
I look at other parties where
there what's going on anish giri won u
hikaru nakamura that ended one of
parties there somewhere it looks like a draw
someone, well, in general, it’s so Fabiano here
caruana swish and it looks like fabian is there
no there are some we won't but we won't
get distracted let's concentrate on
shorter than we have the first result
Anish Giri beat Hikaru Nakamura
quite unexpectedly i'm even rather rather
on the contrary, we would expect so here
suggested an exchange of queens or something
2 queens are offered to be exchanged by the way
I feel I missed a little sd7 announced
will give in if you went back and forth in
hope that maybe somehow karyakin
knight will make a mistake 4 queens on e7 bishop
returns to d3
through over it
Karjakin is such a movie so simply not
get through yes it costs and costs nothing
wants now spinning 2 maybe not
all the same there to return to the idea to take
she no go heart 2
I don't even see how I went and played somehow
scrapped would one in the woods played the words would
one pro led the king on barely there
king to 8 knot would be one this
already somehow from a great mind, yes, but somehow
just apparently moving back and forth of times
rearrange the market yeah that's bye bye
but waiting on the other side waiting somehow
a little pressure, it can still be mined
karyakin lure on time so everything
the remaining 5, but by the way, maybe closer to
look at the blackboard starts
raise the proboscis yes there somehow
queens in 5 goes somewhere, that is, with
random yes by repentance no threats
she punishes the filthy won king
anand defeats fabiano caruana yes but
something ukraine goes this this tournament
clearly that is that is Fabiana so and so and
stuck there in a deep red on the truth
and nantes herd u she date too everything is so there
looks like Aronian will win against
mamedyarov and black, yes, you have a draw here
hello gram with grischuk he himself and not
mistaken it looks like it was the most
long party that it will also be already 4
Yes, it’s interesting to start repenting for us, as well as
supposed to start and canopy
transformation to position 4 here
played took took if the glass is not 4 he
just beat this horse and dad goes the same
5 before that is he is already trying well then there
what happened played the sun 8 even 5 here
they are 4 mine to anyone here at all
still probably white give pressured
not such a queen will take and then
offers free so 2 then I'll go yes oh here
heart 20 queen f3 do not change date but
then already might fierce 6 somehow a
the truth is x 6 well then it is necessary to sell
reckon with firsov, then the crisis begins
2 yes and on a horse 2 employees
well, I think in white how they lost to me
it seems because there is always
even in this variation, White has eternal
step should be through d6 and there
somewhere from 28 to night write the power to the baby
their
what will beat off sergey karyakin you are sent 4
thought and thought took in such a queen 20
seconds remains with Sergey for about a minute
you forests all the rest of the tour party
ended by the way, that is, on this
since we guessed with the choice, we would have guessed
by the way, unexpectedly even beat two
he exchanged about himself, this is nothing
scoops it twist surprise because
just well, you know, well, you can do it
jump here all over the board yes yes well
Horse [ __ ] Completely Dominates Elephant
so well, about a pawn on 4, it’s worth a lot
far away from the queen of the kid and maybe
pericles marshal he is to them at the center yes a
by the way its probably think that this
a fortress, yes, that is, maybe a snag
Yes, that's how it is, White can't break through
zone and filming he's 3 but that's how he is
puts the horse wondering well then the husband too
elephant and in Tripoli he does not depart no no
departs and how it will become almost like at 3 and
played king c3 sums in 3 to king and
6 percent sent 3
but it looks like a fortress
the fortress seems to be black
just walk like an elephant don't line up yeah yeah
so they went out to play
for a moment it seemed to us
you have a preponderance of the forest, but actually
it's over the first round is over
very fast very fast we expected that
can go on for more than 20 minutes
so the results of the party which we saw
in from the woods karyakin the party is over
draw Mamedyarov loses to Aronian
fabiano caruana loses to vichy anand
he might even do something
make out look so your eating count
draw with grischuk he beats anish giri
hikaru nakamura is also unexpected
the result is a hole so that is from the leaders y
us half a point kvass forest approached
lebanon earlier yes maybe look at
standings how things have changed
if we have yes yes here we have after all and have
us after each that is a gap in common
and a half smoothing
Ryan comes out on a clean 2 and oh by the way
by the way, this is only the first round already
twenty half it's up to pos all all yes
nothing to fill everything depends of course
will depend
and from the game you are with the fox and from the game coming
pursuers because the same levon
he won both strong blitz tournaments and but
By the way, Karyakin is four points behind, yes
for 17 games then Karjakin can also
maybe a karyakina rose, or because we are like
remember that karjakina us ex-world champion
blitz
amateur add on half dollars
Turin is absolutely right yes that's all
who is watching sergey karyakin knows them
what happened happens that moment when
it seemed that all hope was already lost
victory in the tournament and here here usually
such a finishing spurt follows
and by the way, it’s not clear where it’s not for him, but
due to what where does sergey find energy
before to add to the very same
everything falls out of hand like a bad shape
everything and suddenly adds and
but apparently others may just be more
more for others and more tired then well
that let's be quick if there is
the opportunity to see how or replayed
Nakamura is a reminder of the party which
first ended first ended
first round if we have the opportunity
show this is the final position and here
what we had we had
berlin weaker 1 in 1 substitution we discussed
that everything is quiet and calm, yes, but how
how confused hikaru is not h4
the horse barely exchanged
but looks pretty like this without api yet yes
as long as nothing like that happens
verbatim at 4 went all here
walked and walked while everything seems to be cultural
queen f3
it’s not clear where where how I beat it to scrap
e5 here are the servants 6 as an exchange of char outdoor
this may be a little but by the way
sometimes she looked more active
symmetrical but the line is behind white as
there is no special counterplay for Black, and here is
he himself is already upholstered, yes, like we are nasty
studied there our 5 slumber system of Tatars
already a little unpleasant position so through
dcm played took took check gives fergie 5
threaten to climb 6 but nothing is allowed
like this, probably 6 end 5 yes that's it
this one is in danger very seriously
find cast schemes or just horse again
right away, in fact, there are threats, but that is
here from hell straight straight of course
pink no h5 knight f6
ah, that's it, that's it, that's it, that's it
explanation yes because next year
who nakamura made it sure move
on the same ruin life is not done and everyone
a6 c6 just gives up a pawn and goes to the end
to some extent, the university will already give change
here hazing is already doubts already
just fell down well and then weights
didn't seem to have any problems
there's all the same pressure on
kingside only a pawn extra
but just look at 100 recent
her h4 here h5 everything is very logical knives 63
the shield was exchanged here, by the way, you can
state the fact that 6 is again not
came out of debuts even can hikaru yes
seems to have happened because he was lulled
such a calm option gives everything
probably thought anything but such
positions are usually given in any way
catastrophe
interesting that we can't even
tell me where I went wrong, yes, somehow
looked the same then a little u
whites better then hop and
and and victory over no time for black pimples
appear and develop figures as it should
well, actually, what else do we have
let's probably not do it
Perm is not much time left
let's see better what we have
still there were parties your crown anand
let's see how
and she fabiano caruana played with anand
let's see the fabiano part
caruana with vichy anand yes well here they are
somewhere from the debut we'll try yes here
this is what we had it was protection for him
savicha with the move e3 with the move the knight is barely
this is not the most popular option.
trying some flexible structure
get here a3 and here is interesting a
three here is the move bishop e7 to which here
often turns out to be some kind of Canadian
the so-called white structure is beaten on
t5 here is hunting an elephant up to 6 such a little bit
provocative before trying
hello here
in this variant in this variant as if
d6 is better in this variation, as if
in our case it is worth it but the move of the elephant is up to 6
provokes white to play c5
well, actually, yes, here it is
provocation c5 fabian played c5 b4 so
just this position with a big
White's space advantage somehow
gradually black twisted and
won let's see for ourselves sinan
deliberately took the risk of cherry something
it's harder to get this I think
this is more or less standard before they took
took here the elephant first goes to 6 we
usually what happens is black tries
exchange the bishop and then somewhere later
close change the elephant you are not on the horse
probably wait to exchange
white-field elephants and then already 6 to 5
with full responsibility until reshuffle
Bishop c4
goal of the system but it improves
by the way at 4 somehow 4 that itself start on
the icon is not of course, although it may be e5
wanted to play vichy maybe wanted to
play e5 so f4 here we take it
new somehow pawn it and on it can
cause more damage
space and that's b5 well, such a position
they keep this black even somewhere with an elephant
there passive yes and the quality of sleep you get on
c4 should be the full order of das
as if 7 even keeps very often not
boarding house e5 rook f8 i.e. ready at 24
up called 12 4 up suggest yeah well
then pc
the line is opened and potentially very
dangerous ashes dapper fp1 exchanged for
and 5.7 in general you can somehow beat
say here's a new one by the way here
instruction 4 to very responsible
decision elephant c4 bc cuni barely yes that is
took took opened opened and created a line
walkthrough protected alonso 4 already
his terrible move, and here I am still very
I like the move made by anand queen
b7 i.e. doubling along the b-file with a threat
pick up on c5 before using the pin
line bay just cavalry 5 threatens and
I had to call and how terrifying
ugly move had in particular
fb2 otherwise you have the sun 4 on the investigation yes
and therefore there is no way to protect such
i horse c3 couldn't go maybe
Martens 3 still had to be played simply
move rook b2 of course here rook b2 just
I don't know horror by the way yes at the end of 3 well
probably the same thing you followed
in this polish played earns
again, you can’t show the children yes he
dacha we are here transformation
advantage before traded and gains
the eternal knight on e4 the rook would be one
kunai 4 dead sun 3 well somehow fabiana
here resisted let's already like this
fast view to queen d2 king
h8 this facing and moves are typical such
just in case before depart
h3 h6 king h2 wot blitz and still
difficult to play a completely logical game
yes, that is, some such small
practical solutions when just a move
just rearranged figurine it too
it happens, well, sometimes it happens without sharply yes
even an account for a little bit and without risks here
gradually and now the rook comes in the rook
8 and the rook goes to 2 before all the same
dominates gradually outplayed and then
already had to beat on b3 passer
the strongest b2 won here
just won the piece b5 cb
I would 5 so that's all the same until the very end
but you know, yes, look c 6 h 4
the system is beautiful we say blitz
blitz and it's nice to hold
queen with a check and after the move the king already
eat up the inevitable mate our one if
rook b1 go so powerful body deb and 1 a
can can never zone possibly and
lose like this like this and yawn
gave days b1 and here is highway 22
here we took it and here we took it therefore
in fact, apparently there are six
I think about the plant, unless it remains
one was made yes of course black
win so much page 5
so wait does black win one
second but if than to them somehow h4
exuberant at 6 moved to earlier
trilogy 3 check of the check of the king h7
By the way, I do not understand why such positions
play even in close it's still 611
thrill 11 5 well, that's what he tried
even up to some trick but here is
marten 3 and the horse goes on from the 5th
delays the pawn system then here already
it's time to admit because to say
outplayed outplayed
Vichy Fabian again a little
depressive party for the crown well
you didn’t work out on your debut somehow
overplays him okay if he yawned
this is fixable so quite easily that is
decided the tactics, came the form successfully, but
somehow replay it is not clear when
maybe it's just the length
compensates with the bill yes here here here
somehow while it is better to manage
game by the opponent and let me remind you what else
we had one winning game
shakhriyar mamedyarov
lost with White Levon Aronian
this allows Aronian to cut
a little gap but we will prepare
already by the second round, yes, apparently in a couple
minutes is no longer my old who tour yes
let's see what's there
happens give us from the foal so still
times hikaru nakamura vs sergey
karjakina will play levan aronian will
play sense with this again
the most interesting couple i somehow what u
a thriller awaits us here, almost everything is waiting for us
the most interesting games with the participation of
forest yes but you have to excuse me but
we'll have to look again behind
party in from the woods is not that we strongly
circumstances were unhappy with this
there is no discrimination for you, but we just look
on the leader yes you're just trying yes then
there is who
will overtake in from the forest here will fall into our
hit parade that become the star of our air
and so for whom once karjakin im anand
vs mom dior water
they on vasilisa are a couple who
we will watch grischuk play fabiano
caruana
and anish giri will fight with maxim
your kilogram, that is, let's probably
immediately turn on this party will be
judging let's watch Aronian of course
let's watch Aronian from here it seemed
would yes such a comfortable break chicago hour
if you win, it’s already left for vulnerable white
went crust remains one and a half points lemon
so picks up speed to 3 2 of 2 more 16
for another 16 party and a half points
out of 16 parquet not so much and yes so
but wounded seems to have completely blocked
debut repertoire and here he is playing
only e4 yes it looks like in this tournament
only and 4 played French Defense
and here is luigi 3 by the way very interesting
such a move qe7 though strong even with the
to the horse by the way by the way isn't it here
easy as too 4g 4 played on 4 kind of us
such a nazar of tasks studied in the 30s
even put 5 pawn yes, well, that's 3
still with him and 7 bishop but 2 knight f6 and
here is such an interesting move kuni barely
they are at the exchange of the icon Tue and I barely have vodka
not to
do not block the diagonal of the white-field
elephant
but the truth is, the horses are hardly like that here Vovka
new model shields at the border 4 2 rooms
3 maybe then castling castling
till
Well, does anyone over there know what he's doing?
somehow not yet true and impressive
exchange come in and 5 each of the face
pretty comfortable here called well
wait wait I what and can not yet
aligned offers d3
plays through the t3 filter, well, that's already
some even a pawn to sacrifice
having bought it is impossible so often such already
passed frilly yes a little bit although we have 6
by car's map if he doesn't want to
contact here transition is not
I like it to be honest, I thought in this one
positions might be worth oddly enough
just fall back on the same 2 pre
so that the knight on f6 must
yes, it’s just not up to 4 to them black in Genk
well, a little more active elephant killed them
by the way, if black would go here
such a typical move with 6 we could even
sun 66 is we set 788
possession 1 cute yes indeed
so but here I went first d-30
overcomes me he takes on e5 from her
5 exchange of queens for v8 vantage from not
should be watched 4 apparently well
although it may be like at 4 really
but I think blacks can even
calmly react go elephant to 60
layers took daladier he has not yet
full text one put took to sleep and in
four zones in 4 and sleep and in 6 leaving me
I thought maybe an elephant up to 6 is already powerful yes
and well, the next move for black sun 4
or elephant h3 yes it looks like it succeeded
play on that pawn on over all
hangs yes because there
extreme case, here I am not leading the way
say some lodent and 1 up per turn
water up to 16 and by the way handbags are powerful
shotgun of the law shnyre up to the heights of the same 4tb
more dangerous for whites so let me here
just in case, I'll keep an eye on
the rest of the parties a little but for now
everywhere is normal as it is logical
development there are no by the way believers
circumstances these grischuk pawn
donated against the wishes of the crown yes there
interesting development but we
let's still be there for now for now
here while here we stay from the moon at 4 so
you come back let's go to the position on the board
actually because no no m 3 here
after the move
what are you what i don't like it
whites is the lion king 2 plan to come up
gave when great d1 like that already
can get heart 6 ladian d1 all
I went to d1 somehow the bishop can go
he does not reduce 66 and probably will
three horses need to be cut a little somehow
to play three, well, somehow it seems to me already
White really needs to be careful
play to perhaps repaid the course
equalities
it is not clear, yes, due to what, yes, it will
fight that's just how they played
servants 6 b3
but it means 1 either we are good at
either they are in bad shape yes yes yes yes i
after all, blitz is easy enough
guess the moves up to, except for some here
supernatural naturally yes it happens
sometimes it is necessary to say that all the same on Tony
and top grandmasters up to that sometimes even in
blitz give out some fantastic
the quality of the park for just such
logical ideas here we think enough
competent to guess here again
by the way good to 5 4 5 but I like 3
can disturb white's queenside
yes, and it looks like you will have to be happy
whether bath doroshina equation play but
noted
note that the position is very much in style
you have a face and not at all wounded in spirit
hurt would prefer of course something yes
livelier to jump there with figures
Moreover, he understands perfectly well that
victory would be promoted by an important sweet
given no white pieces present all present
such a thousand m back here is a horse then maybe
be 25 goes by the way denominations
some move back on the squeeze while but though
male c5 can he again wants a
By the way, don't pick up or just an elephant, but I
I will quote the words of the days does not force
exchanging an elephant for him no words are needed
retreat
and when 4 was impossible it was just our 3d a
here is the bishop c7 of the same to my set
it looks like yes it's here bringing his family not
guessed hodson system that horses in four
or maybe he'll let you go first
although he would not send 6 to prevent h5
before
you can although the sun of all there are 6 and 3
her character is 8 so wait
okunev 4xy is there any 4 at the end of 5
probably yes you horses six wins
end 5 played yea what takes on and 6
levon here questions yes here questions what
what to do in if possible
Top 6 Act 6 He's not afraid of being
the notorious advantage of two bishops before
maybe there is no advantage
somehow Alana has a benefit maybe
be and no yes he if all fields are black
control so quite reliably u
mice played and then bishop e7 so and now
collapsible exchange of bell under
the size of the black box is generally no worse than any
district
but usually in such positions you go for 5
I will agree here the sun 5 here
literally next move yes yes horse horse
25 pages and arrows won't edge a couple
yo so elephant and v2 that summer was walking up to the elephant
c2 like c5 and like from 5 like this
its the most-very appearance of the knight on c5
which we spoke to the data but it is possible with
confidence to assume that this white
they definitely won’t win the game, I can’t
present as as such under position
you can lose clearly blitz sometimes yes
there are catastrophic
situations when there and a piece in one move
yawned well, but there is simply nowhere
make a mistake with the logical development of the party
of course it's hard to imagine black like that
a lot of king to the center on the lead korolev
8 I think maybe one pair of Laurent Barbara
too - waved bad it's time to start already 6
in general, at least somewhere else it doesn’t spoil here
to clarify where the bishop is going h3 see
recedes yes well and now
grime yes they will change loydi later
queens 8 will go so the exchange is here everything
very logical and
very logical meander korolev 8 there
king at random sem cover fields
by the way, well, probably not
it's hard to imagine what we'll do when playing
there and it looks like
can expect that he will get confused where
then it will most likely be
draw
I don't even know what washes me out
called somewhere to switch to
interest agree and party if here
by the way, we have already finished despite
tie on and i'm a midland
mamedyarov we have a draw yes so it is with nakamura
there is some kind of struggle with Karyakin, but here
well, let's do it all the same, yes here
let's wait a bit, maybe there
they repeat easily you look like this hike
somehow repeated no no emphasis slope 6
the ends of the 5th if standing still before aroyan
no aronian sun 4 thousand some
still it's some kind of progress
pushing up trying for five already five
it's brazen that's logged 6 king same 7 but
all the same, the black fields are very strong
I think a draw is a natural result yes
by the way, we can turn on the baptism of the Koran
this is a newbie quran this is exactly what the party is on
which I would like very much
I don't know if we have one
I don't know if you have the opportunity
chance it still we'll have up to
end to end stay with parties
sparta vasilisa well we can't in every
round yes we can’t guess in every round
guess sometime sometime yes maybe
turn out that the party is not the most interesting
coal miner with caravans grischuk without quality
well, in appearance in a very very promising
positions
worthy forgiven that fabiana and the second
consecutive defeat will suffer before the main
just dominate in that party like this
here we have that here we somehow have everything
very very calm before exchanged
again the feast on f1 leaves lego
so so so 4 played in if a i i
I didn't even fully believe my own
eyes same 4 played in if not pick up
because dokoni 4 plug everything is very
very simple and prosaic i.e. the sun
2 probably or dream e 2d
Bishop e2 can already be guaranteed already Jura
snakes on the capture of an elephant and even marten 4
took took yes water until 7 seems to have
whites are more active, well, you can get along on
p4 put somewhere then take off
hot swap it but it
apparently not necessarily not necessarily
blacks are no worse than they lead 14 him everything
still I realized that if you love him before
simplification in general she has four solar
logical need to see the lessons okay them
endings are better than the grandmasters of the planet
free free lessons laden them
endings so need to own up to 7 will play
does he have no queens 3 yet some truth
sad kerf I draw and finally we are with
full right switch to the party
grischuk pocket here there here there there here
something very interesting is happening
let's switch immediately
Fabiana there time quite and by the way
looks like an overwhelming guy and then
let's see something from the beginning
it was very interesting, yes, but here
it looks like he pressed the ropes
the problem is that the king absolutely can
habitually somehow 4 still adds korolev
8 yes, the rook is stuck on the same 6 to on and
the king by the way is also stuck in the king
harold ondar h4 played alexander king
8 they haven’t gone anywhere and you can
you can go here this sympathy thought
generally leave as an elephant, put y on d3
tank floor 5 you can play there and so
so as much as 5 to 6 well, that is, do not beat this
rook at all never to absolutely
futile I even have a position for black
you played very beautifully there
for this we will return to this yes
well, look here the bishop played e2
played h5 here it is the final position
sasha grischuk wins and what the hell fabiana
up to 2 in a row is clearly not defeated by him
the tournament suffers the second defeat in a row
if we have something else in the process hikaru
nakamura plays sergey karyakin us
looks like no true south paddles gram yet
party go on let's go on hikaru
pass hikaru nakamura vs.
karjakina so well from the camera we only
unfortunately nothing to see by have to
perhaps yes, turn on the board now
you have to turn on the board, but it's hard
curly ending occurs well or not
knew it also dmitry spiers probably
they took something they didn't take me yes
there is a trap up to 1 pawn capture but five each
queens give everyone later matters of 8
correctness by the stitches of Karjakin's trial
of course you won't spend it like that yes yes yes yes
that there is some kind of transition at the end
outlined
but there are probably still equal pawns
five also 6 treat it hands
flicker and they have little time for
but it doesn't seem to start
3g
lagg-3 here nakamura somehow keeps holding
on the beach in this one, I don’t know what it is
voltage up to but in my opinion at 6 nothing
they need to keep
ended relogio didn't try to get dressed
trelawney normal well everything just as soon as
exchanged exchanged one pair of pawns
royal this while wheedling it out
trying trying to mod just become
miss the king, but by the way he could
try h4 and h5 as not leg and he
returned returned to f3 so well here
let me try
as I said very much
quickly calculated everything, I would now have 5 rook
over with this rook b1 and logged to 6 so a
what is happening there
king and all babies 6 but walks on
looks like it's just going back and forth
cries again found it some way
just stand still and do nothing
but now it will be a long time
just like equals
but impenetrable impenetrable looks
just like an equal lodey ending before
what
nakamura masha what not flat she fled
on foot west 3 ran pawn to patria
and they change that 3 for 3 that poured money
will play on the nose will not will not
play ended draw so draw y
nakamura rather throw anand a draw
modeled whose meaning has dropped
grischuk defeats karl well it looks like we
missed this movie no score and
defeat your loggers they steps up very
everything happens so fast
let's get your loggers catching up with the aronians
look at the table, I'm already confused
on the radio outside
aronian his village count for two and a half
point you half point from two to 2.2 and
once the table behind each actor is all
it gets harder let's rethink
effective let's reconsider
party, well, I even propose to start with
kettlebells and your kettlebells don't start with the party they
rivage kilo steps there up to some
at some point it turned out that
equals and ending on chalkboard
it seemed that the ending was equal on the board
that's it let's say I'm not 2 that whites is
serious problem must be at the end
they have a rook behind a passed pawn
pawns yes maybe
or just bent the floor lion king 2
Sasons in one year for 4 well, as there is no white
it's easy to make a draw sometimes they want to
it seems that he is still multisim but what about
lost and lost here allowed the king
on c5 we don't seem to be a disaster here
stop yourself wait okay everything is fine
owned again shox you 5 king b6 bishop c4
rook 3 is all right and then for some reason
king two followed [ __ ] shaking on
4 well, this one is willingly like 4 like this
on the edge of the board is really inconspicuous
but the king really believed in gt3
they are even the most terrible and sleep wipe
can enhance his grandfather 6 and words three out
coins and 6 and then getting along I took up
took away, that is, she is kept here
powerfully this is a villa and in their park
happened next king on b2 bishop
beats 4 and now if you give check and king
c5 the bishop is already too far he is already
too much
easy yes and that is king 3 king
up to 6 and here it's not possible to pick up in
one move on c4 in general a cruel game yes
yes yes he is up to 5 food king c5 just
stayed without haste hastily mother well something
wised up something wised up like anish
weights and defeats your loggers and here
grischuk oscar party it looks like a witch
mastered the very case of the fish outplayed
grischuk let's see that is
Another Sicilian by Fabiano
caruana here i saw six by six
montag he played europe you something he
loses here too regularly
replace debut ec7 elephant d3o not in 6 well
it looks like some kind of theory
scrapping b4 here is the bishop d2 by the way, the same move
their shields of the form may or may not be 4
the sacrifice of this pawn on f4 is essentially
pawn sacrifice because here is service 4
have to walk the elephant before 2 took well and
of course, do not try something, but
he took on f4
sacrifice a pawn gets the most powerful
Ternopil on the elephant is played out on and
control over all black flying is an elephant
played a role we'll see what until the end of the 6th
deev one queen already 4 step same 3 i.e. not
I was surprised with difficulty in general
prepared firm 4 took on c6 villains
6 no brilliant from the most beautiful dacha
the game gave the day f6 the exchange of the bishop and v6 and and
5 that is without pure quality yes just
the elephant will give for the pancake, well, what a syllable, but
like f6 you are standing and the villains are a couple of pawns here
you know that's not for maybe
in general, it was worth thinking about someone's move
there keeps warm 6 although position by us
the position of the opposition is probably the same as
position all the laces already can you can
jump cursing might turn out to be that
it's just quite quite a call not
just look the name is very cute
before implementation, that is, for isolation
actually all the rook pieces on the same 8
clueless king on and 8 constantly
falls under some kind of threat to the planet
one played the pot there stroking so
we sew the elephant's moves, give windows there d1
maknoth will follow 8 followed by d7
teamwork
he is not 4, well, black has 2 rooks, none
of them doesn't work very well
i would be 80 v3 calmly slowly walking
just comes over over here this pawn on
as many as five planets and 6 is also so cool
move here set how they come out black
roots nails nail down sent c6 elephant
beats hp like d5 b2b 34 here for 4
have otherwise white still themselves c4
will play c4 king e3 is playing 4 well
maybe not sure about 4
maybe it was worth it and immediately the elephant will be returned and
that's say there take her take this rook
it's impossible already to aerate times it
if only but here just 4 and ran
ran you give 744 because nothing
spoils to get probably the same here
it turns out yes and here it contains 6 here
of course nice h4 and don't take it
rook on 6, that is, but it is clear that here
this position it must be won yes
i.e. whites
2 extra pawns are too many and active
all 2 extra pawns too before too
active piece but why capture the rook
who can't go anywhere
Bishop e2 b4 h5 owning f6 here when
Fabian Yes seems to have bought off the material
relief did not come
by the way again some kind of depressive
party for crown fans
outplayed him just as if without a chance
this is a very debut idea, unfortunately
knowledge does not allow me to say here
played if in 4 date what's here what's here
what's new here well it looks like this
that's all down to logged villains 6 if
it might very well be even
home prepared if it's all right
then it looks like very very strong
debut idea in well bravo alexander
dobrov alexander really is about
what to think if what to think karla not
voronin's draw sense sit down here
some a little colorless turned out
yes, the rest of the parties there are a little bit drawn
we are on
yes liza for hikaru nakamura sergei
Karyakin I don’t know what they have there
happened well and anand looks like anand
Mamedyarov is also all there on business, yes
maybe a little quick here
time allows another 10 minutes before
start of the next round
take a quick run through anand's game
see omidyar and like this and like this to mom 1 5
Rubinstein played this variation
I liked it, it's the same as theirs
in rapid it was up to a partner who
mamedyarov won
we are harbored there and in rapid
Vishy played e5 and e6 Rapide Vishy played and 5
6 but here it is still called
changed my mind
gives a chance b5 changes beat disgraced bishops
and then after 5 black simply retreats to
same 8 and after moves up to 46 it turns out
this is the french structure
French defense which are pretty
comfortable for black background for black
something that is already stupid as usual
globe smart elephant 108 somehow everything
cultural figures here come into play you
honestly it's just look castling
knight c6
equestrian 2 retreats here that's donara
practical solution to trade for three
four now 2 get lucky on c6
that is, blacks have no problems at all
experience i finish off 6 took took well
Seems like
even wants to be white, that is, even
even black is more pleasant with a hail of black and
perhaps nicer, well, if here
assume that white is some two
they will make such not very energetic hells
black played a short scheme from the moon
castling yes so black will generally be
pleasant approved 4 somehow a little vichy
interferes with the development of the kingside a6
by the way no 80 photos 6 a little she to
our pawn on itself just didn't hang yeah
by the way, somewhere around 30 would be so funny
see if us video by
did 61 will be settled 1 2 3 0 this is
impudent, yes, but I didn’t have time not in this
this situation she
probably not in time probably not in time
badly there say unfortunately somewhere
here before castling long is not devoid of
meaning just you can view to
have time to go king would 8 baby 8 but
here of course I don't know 4 1 to 4 maybe
be yes there wore she didn't think maybe in
400 is the same as before a6 move can still
was a possibility 3 0 so long ago asem no
and there there saying goodbye to the fish always
more than a hundred bass roles here and there
will start like they would now fun to 4
there again they took they took on b6 well
please figure superfluous that you can even
than just extra you can even go to fish 6
collect yes well understand well well blitz
nevertheless, they decided to be more reliable
heart 4 is changing queens here too
you can understand in your own way c4
Well, it looks like Vichy has already started here
at night to fight for a draw even in some
sense can be said in short 6
c5 bishop e7 and here is c6 often killed
them bad can become really bad could
it could be bad to turn to the right is c6
here is what you need gave them both 8
it turns out korolev one again and what and
pretty colorless here already
it's nothing, it's simple, it's simple
it turns out a draw rsi ravana i.e.
lose a white pawn but here are the logs asem
king to 8 radio 8 no way
scholars escape the thing ours but forged
here to do everything on the case, well, like this
surprise from the mamedyarovs and the knight f6 on
second move literally birds elian move
famous but not used very much
good reputation at the highest level as
the rule does not occur but I can only
to say that all the same attempts some
denial of an attempt to gain weight gain
must be associated with code e4 e5 yes
it also seems more fundamental
still walker not in the center it's such a little bit
modest but also vichy a couple of times
tried one lost here
a draw arose, well, we have a table
I hope let's see what the situation is
after two rounds to see the situation
after two
tours and either in fact it is already
rounds passed 11
Let me remind you that we have one common tournament
it does not have up to 9 rapid chess rounds
and plus an additional 18 blitz rounds
2 of them have already played, that is, again
draw for thoughts your property was
the main pursuer
lemon aronian om and pull up after
victories there maxims included logrov thousand
15 in from the woods for 12 and a half a wounded
Logrov 11 at Karjakin, that's some way
some distance has already been outlined
one and a half points between before between kept a
cow and that's sergey karyakin
distance between karjakin im out oh now
four points
ten and a half hikaru nakamura's
nine and a half smart for the frame and
Grischuk and the topic Korlan and 6 half
ananda on clean last even after
victory over nakamura in the previous round
yes, on a clean last they shared by the way
we formed and lost
formed such a trio of losers I
would say yes yes yes tournaments if
see yes there are top three before
thoughts and
Aronian entered and and your kilogram later
this is the middle of the tournament
tables from 11 to nine and a half
points yes, that's all at a distance
one and a half points we have 4 chess players
there is such a stuck something in
middle of the standings and three
underdogs quite determined yes
still at a distance of one and a half points, that is
this crown buckwheat is already two and a half
points but necessary.
that is, there is already not even catching up
so let's just see for sure
Grischuk is there, but I still wouldn't cheat
from accounts blitz yes that is if he
it will be so possible to play as he spent
fabiano caruana part
then how can know how can know
alexander will show here yes yes
quite capable
and so what are we going to prepare for
Let's get ready for the next round
next round let's see
let's see the lot that we have five there
minutes points total remains your ate graph
Nakamura will play in out of the woods
will play with Vishy Anand Fabiano
caruana vs anisha giri is here
meeting there in the lower half of the tournament
da table go logger nakamura and
Mamedyarov Grischuk and Karjakin Aronian
and I have this unexpected
a proposal to digress from the parties of the leader and
on this tour try to see
karjakina with karjakina saran she can
maybe try the same tired
a little forest from you yes, bye-bye here
how then are they not not particularly something
interesting yes the parties of the party developed in
if
maybe before a sergei karyakin always
Let me remind you that strong is very near
let's try to look there
I wonder probably eels pike with you
Germana all the same for this by the way two
contender such well that is a party
also karjakina and mom dior two parties
interesting everyone is already seated it seems
dutton members here is this couple
Fabiano Caruana vs Anisha Givi
of course they would like to have a little
another result meet up
yamashita same suggest cheek play style
look at the grischuk tomato
really let's look at
I'll show you look at Grischuk and he's already like that
fully committed to victory
immersed party looking for started while grischuk
already fully immersed in
reflections trying up to make a decision
what kind of debut will we play there yes yes
so let's look at Sasha
alexander grischuk with black vs shahriyar
mamedyarov adana not allowed all the time
shows here comes our leader behind
board there too show face passes
let's see let's see
a little bit and in the middle of the table too
look at the batch of grischuk tomatoes
I honestly don't know Mamedyarov
like his results, he is not the best
high re
in blitz and what are his results in such
tournaments but here is a memory from
let's say once we crossed Shahriyar
them when he just got up
or something like a crush on some common windows
tournaments, I remember that there was such
discipline he liked to give odds to some
with his comrade from Azerbaijan there
who played weaker liked to give
a head start of 30 seconds versus just five minutes
for you to receive dear friends
idea about you got an idea about
how fast can he play
he take on the party was taking 30 seconds without
without any addition i.e. we
it's just fantastic now sometimes
something like practicing online in
donate the Internet with a mouse
of course you can do it with a move like a muscle
click faster than before rearrange
figures but in general colossal plethora
here we have gathered but absolutely about
any yes that is, here is an outsider anish
kettlebells called try shoals
play a match on the lower blitz yes
we'll see what happens but I wouldn't
I would like to participate in such an undertaking yes well
and that we are ready for like a couple of minutes
maybe we have a minute
let's remember what it's all about
fight that's it call up let's go
let's see let's see here
the game goes on up and what are they for
fighting on the channel if I'm not mistaken
$150k total prize pool
tournament
the total prize fund of the tournament is 150 thousand
dollars and the winner will receive 37 s
half of these 70 out of 70 and you are already out of the woods
you already know something like this, I think he is a couple
once we check but I think he does
plans how to make plans how to spend but
it's still early no actually here you are in
interview him now here is his
naturally interviews after each
days and he behaves very very modestly
and he says it's still early on about it
it's not over yet, but we
turn on dear friends to the party
alexander grischuk shakhriyar mamedyarov
Well, here comes the originality.
slot g5 played dobrushe 5 still ok
you are just an indian that you have previously
evidence of combat could play up to 5
greenfield he plays too no he
selects country day aka 5h topic 6
and here is not our 4 what is it like this
on d2 until 76, but then it started before 6
heart one plays mom diorama can
grischuk is already 50 m, by the way, our system is 4
and alexander ponyash 5
watched 8 moves played suspect
this is just the first time ever
this position first time shabbat horse again
I understand from the idea of ​​playing f5
obstruct operas don't give h5
go to the site by the way grischuk and in general
almost spent time maybe not even
quite a new position but he understands he
understand these pages very well and
4 slick tomatoes well you know it so
that as there is already two ends important
fall apart as much as they can strain it
now what if you take u can 5 and 5
5 played
and now but what beat it at all
stupid very strange is this one
battery elephant dota 2 queen on t1 to
if the whites don't get there right away, then
looks just as stupid
went can drive already gone 505
blame me beauty layer d3 have to
you can close it yourself with
our king how are you
well, that is, for now, for now, in that area
boards on the queenside
a little alexander, but that's not even
active 10 it's more of a kind
prevention there to put a horse on 6
to slow down that's on the move on
four chains
such a horse horse goes Nazi 565 but by the way
this Russian one on c5 and somewhere later
already fine-tuning 105, the d3 field controls and
somewhere then the vest will go
I understand this design in a hurry to
4 elephant forget yaris verso one like her
interacts something i while
well understand as far as I understand how
I understand what is here
expected from grischuk and what kind of income
some landing bdsm
then the premiers would of course go h5 and
it was already yes, that is, what does it have to do with it
it's quite strong because finally 5
generally immediately 4 yes well even if no
already 4 just now to sacrifice a pawn in
hid the line for the lag then that's it
somehow a little bit but also finds its enthusiasm
makes sense, but what we are now
we see how it was once set
verbatim and double two same 3 plays
covered up easier tyrit bravely probably
because often konig 4 is even a victim
pawns followed well and cavalry 5 that's black
so slowly begin to hang honestly
c1 costs well, frankly, very not very
but on the site heart 2 must be combined
Well, yes, apparently Egorov has already gone out of the slope
three main three played yes that's sometimes up
in these positions the size of the char floor
finally again not as bad as it can
it seems to me that his idea really
case ferris 2 of 3 letter b2 put
cannot bet on d2 but may know about
you can twist the horse 2 this
also possible by the way still find up to
stress to chasing on d2 after all
to leave coins h5 then maybe I'm somewhere
as much as 5 poke and maybe you know lookin at
this position because the words of children can
it's not like that and it just might not be
I know energetically enough
act alexander grischuk about what you can
say yes I already have white position
more like it actually seems
that it’s easier for them to play such structures, well
Now if now it's all the same
immediately f5 there is no move maybe maybe
be about to hook with no
felt the moment he takes such a pause
thought about it, but apparently it’s necessary already in everything
serious
it looks like what, well, let's say if
if something like great experience to
protect the national did not spoil
structure then all the same butorina horse
given
although although may still eat at 5 here
idea here 5 play
yes if there is play them diver if
elephant h5 wrong us will give you 5 for good
until it upsets where we will be from
forget yes let's say they took it away
they took this water, that is, like horses
everyone was beaten by books, all by two or
educational in full order only articles
close by the way maybe white can there
instead of 45 on the previous move, just
beat on again that's a different thing
it's even 4 go took and here 4
works so they took 4
of course Tyrion and why not lead there and
no, this is how up to 3 up to just for
this was exchanged for chains yeah
really but but that's what we did
little energetic move more due to
alexandra and he played he played queens and
8 but he also became an interesting move
among 8 somewhere the previous horse is a man
poison while it's hard to understand but it
defending the h5-knight in order to
option
let's say that's what else pies with
ideally taken if it all happens to
the first defends with and 8 horses our hike
typical actually u up to 38 nothing
the moment has not yet shown a new one
what kind of ferdy 8 here here you can somewhere on
kone b5 run into actually beats
aim mobile app of immediately probably
helsinki how to take and
here we are a little
we lag behind this electronic board
slightly behind the events on the board
real took took played queens 3 and
queen of schemes answers alexander so and here
3 0 then does not go by chance sitting there
somewhere up to 6 stick like this and there is 3 0
and rook 6 is such a move
not the most not the most popular rook 6
horses a4 get attacked by Shahriyar
pawn c5 but b6 will have to be played
saw 16 picture find desire 6 not
there, frankly, not there, well, it looks like somewhere
Grischuk didn't have time to look like Grischuk somewhere
no time you can still not so bad
you can return saladin 8 to recognize
mistake yes well that is b6 go 6 have to
so that 6 seems to have to be seen as
how they can
black sacrifice a pawn successfully yes yes
that is, 6 white should probably be here
grain c canyon 20 is back on center
oh yeah and black go back to 8 go back
on a8 and here it’s not geon d6 it won’t run into
and now I don’t know, but maybe he will go Hongdae 7
booth 7-6 somehow probably will be
they want to put up a blockade, they can smoke
it turned out look so horse horse horse
ice age 5 is finally back on action
well right horse goes on his 7 breathe
here she is here she is the field for the horse
of course, that's it, that's how it is, that's how it is 5
you can give a stupid check like yes well
probably not, of course, I also remove the horse
where also 4 on occasion I take out on a horse 8
already preparing h5 patty
she has 8 yes here you can get
really creepy
positional clamp yes and here is bishop c4
already 4 and if they change beat disgraced
give somehow white rolls queens barely
and then here she is and all these river knife
in my opinion the taxi came from 5 so
the same line
welcome admitted h5 wow yes
again 5 that's amazing so what
white wouldn't be biased the same 4 still wouldn't
played a bust of something I still don't understand what
happening in this a 4 after hp a4 played
covered there so that he would not be disturbed
will give the queenside and the same chakoli even
eat and same what is to something fence
building some kind of fence builds simply
tries to close everything rook 8 it happens
both tanks can serve 4 don't get out
this is also a mystery to me, yes why
I regret that service 7 was frightened and did not want to
how to exchange such an elephant
usually it’s not clear what we have here for me
it's interesting to get some kind of party
but you may know a new round is development
or like that it's all just build a fence
the calculation of the white horse to their 5 will also be transferred
driller played grischuk he is still there with
case to be replaced apparently by the background apparently
this way fierce in 4 is not even a threat
if version 3 we beat food pawns on
road and we will control everything and so
b3 and played the queen on f4 bets like this
is it possible here somehow f3t f3 the elephant would be with
him but it looks like it's a draw something
we didn’t guess very strangely here
speak with a full board and figures on but
just in the system everything is veiled everything
blocked neither party can
no crazy breakthrough to make before
something spawned were like agreed
give really fast enough
draw with us I will post a compass of this
seemed like a very interesting start to
after that it seemed very interesting
so your face is an extra pawn against
ananda what can we see
by the way, communication would be there for mom dior just
he wanted to do more and maybe
maybe Mamedyarov did not mind
swords here shows us in from the forest
against vichy anand if in his element
an extra pawn in heavy pieces
end product last move h4 and that
he immediately became dissatisfied with the building
the roofs answered 1414 attacking the hv4 pawn
had to play so if h5 just
drag irina yes yes yes there was a problem
that itself h5 talagi h4 and on the king same 1
given h5 can't be picked up here small
trouble step one is
never too late to lose never
it's too late to lose that's the point
set of 4
had to play the queen on e7 moves away to
hearts 3
Vishy move h5 queen to 2 somewhere but he
already looks like at the top beat yes here
consolidated off pawn no well pawn on
entry is too weak for white
white somehow somehow untie well
yes, by the way, can be ironed 4 so that
how ferris b2 rook b8 can be
some battery sold queen d2 and
queen 6 is enough via b2
f6 will try another attempt to beat
ananda vlady us ending to the next
it worked out before the king did everything here
some move not really I like f5
and so I decided well probably
should on right then here
really breakthrough e4 is the only one
possibility up to something for something
achieve so there's a rook
gave another step in if the king of all and
logged up 6 plays with white here bbc 4
can not do but then 3 by 2 already
it says even anand do nothing
fire over but it's already gone but on
actually yes we are joking
obviously higher
cool chess player so so so there
everything is still happening f5 already now
here
it's vulgar to say that the strand is good
beat not but if chance by 4 dating they are not
win back the black rush
but when kings 524
king 5th here in this at 95 planet 5
the filter takes away well the same more
less good here he takes 5 check
will give us again, but if it's not too early, won't we
it was good nothing good draw-draw
the king 6 but in short marching the same 5
queens 6 or yes this is the king
life but impossible to win then
then again it's not too late for white
lose can queens 5 enter
run into 24 today for three all a draw
instantly at least three draw instantly well
that one more draw in if sony whose with
vichy anand draw u pockets with weights
so many draws we have someone here
started remains what remains strange
way then your ate count vs 2 samara
let's karyakin r.n.
looks like your not going there wins
nakamura well don't know about let's
let's see karyakin vanya here very much
interesting queen hd looks like what's all
over yes you have nakamura
in general st nakamura it all ended there
looks like it looks like it looks like you won
yes, but we are watching the game
karyakin aronian so well, everything flashed here
here seconds
stay with sergey karyakin with levon
aronian a little bit more time so on
this is also irrelevant I position
on the board there is a pawn on e3 already something. on the
food but I'll try yes there
restore somewhere each block
hearty step hot karjakina beat
impossible
look, well, it's just a monster, that is
saves absolutely any saves
absolutely any position ends 3
for today blitz tour 3 out of 10 which
bobrovich will be played only one
effective in 9 ways
one single winning game
win your kilo over hikaru
nakamura and pub here maybe this one
party we can check us out shortly
see what happened here before
you have a kilo with nakamura, I remind you that
your ate graph has come one step closer to
the leader of whom from the forest and so so the motor
something nakamura played something like that
something called modern defense yes
that is, such
olya protection of pepper without mustelids 6 by the way
Horrible Debut Allows Here Development
say different very comfortable
arrangements for white vodka not in three
far from quite a queen, by the way
it was the party of Zviad history disgusting to
the sea in the same opening he lost to him
start america i.e. man u
whose rating is 200 points less
Kirov more than together, that is, not
understand why nakamura repeats a
after all, the tables are the same, damn it, why say
about on feels apparently in these positions
h3 took took e5 although positions
objectivity is better than provocative given
c3d 5 the elephant went d3 went that is
some very bad for black pages
to language protection yes, well, it’s just not clear
why leave yourself and the very beginning in
a position where you are much worse then
there must first align
and then already play to win then I
then I'll switch somewhere to go to
thirtieth let's go on a special
and well, where for somewhere here apparently already and
it got much worse yes took it here
such an ending to everything yet
equally well, but a pawn out of 5 is lost, but
then the twig must walk the village 5
to no queen
probably good chances to keep black
but with a queen, the role is weak and superfluous
pawn well, won-won maxim here
let's see go even change here
such a stud role 3 yes and here he won well
let's quickly gradually from
pushes the king distracted nice role
a couple of cats are already distracting such a passage in
legs king d8 find on 6 evolve
king c8 b7 and king just takes
all pawns just all pawns gradually
falls well pretty party in
fulfilling your kilograms but somehow that's
played very convincingly
nakamura debut itself
let's see the tournament this dish
table and I think that we deserve
a little break let's see what
there we have 15 half 813 going on
half clean and second place out
maxim your kilogram is the same one
we criticized for refusing to fight and so
then here you are in second place
never lost a game so far
maybe it's the same celebration standards
pragmatism, that's it Levon Aronian 13
i.e. the triple stays the same
karjakin 11 half ten and a half
at nakamura
10 in mamedyarov with a glitch to everyone with
half of whom she is all anand and na
last on clean last they burned
that is, in fact, except for the victory of Ivashkin
however, murai
the rest of the participants did not move anywhere
everybody panicked
we're taking a little break please
perhaps we certainly cannot
allow to take a break after each
round but so here 1 time after after two
after three games we will sometimes leave
stay with us for a short break
until the start of the next round remains about
10 minutes to be back
[music]
No
and lamented bringing another one with kate moss
my cup of bad baby alive
work moment we are in la reserve merman
texts and even my
son now club marine team play game
the hour is now warehouse salabay
tape it is easier not everywhere everything is said
worry candles from blues
world of tanks rent kissing loubie
I am a manager
worth the gods of labor sirin disco music you
gay + distant + metabo
[music]
discard complete this site is always
explore
[music]
like
but
[music]
already dear friends after the break again
we return to the building of the town hall of the city of Li
you need where the first stage of the tournament takes place
grand chef tournament series verge hour tour
the first stage is called yonic dreams
your next move is a tournament in lebanon yes and y
we are scheduled the fourth for today until 4
for today blitz tour 9 games in total
will be played while in the lead in from the forest
still remind that in the studio for you
work
Yaroslav lived side by side with Evgeny Miroshnichenko and
we will watch in this fourth round
just the party leader the party would have with the face
who will play with black with alexander
Grischuk he is, and so we will be with one eye
look at him in the nearest park
stalker in out of the woods
this is our maxim your logrov which
will play fabiano caruana other couples tours
this is anish giri vs shahriyar mamedyarov
it's Vishy Anand playing with white as sergey
karyakin im and hikaru nakamura as white
will try to improve the standings
against Levon Aronian and here you go
screen on your draw 4 rounds by yourself
The tour will start in just a couple of minutes.
I saw that they were already returning
returns to the playing area players
By the way, there is hope that Grischuk will be able to
how to improve your standings
By the way, compete for the main three prizes
that is, the previous round me is
the feeling that it is still a little
amnestied
c didn’t go to bishop g4 then yes, that’s not
got such dominance on white fields
we were worried about the previous batch of tank
for fate alexander grischuk hell against
against the mamedyars, well, here it is
there really was a little amnestied
with White Alexander won very much
nice party to rouen and today in
in general we will see what is called
how does it turn out yes you until it's better
all players look the same looking for grischuk
looks very put together
everything is concentrated in him everything is in him
so far it's going well oh yes and logr vegetables
too
kilo logrov entered the only well
yes there is vasilisa who is like bye in
his league yes there is
your ate count you face it turns out
two players who have not yet suffered a single
one defeat finally landed logres
today 2 bedroom out of 3 or kadau
entered two and a half out of three before but we
we start sparta grischuk and against if
soda, I think that now we, too, and
they will show what they chose by the way like it
I already have a choice of debut such not in 3d 5 would
three so insinuating so why little by little
a little bit yes here is such of them 3 to 5 b3
so it's like there are 5 of them now
now we will try yes electronic board
also update verbatim in 5 like b2 well
fast enough
play the opening slando opening moves and
6 to 2-3 such a modernist [ __ ] fire
on d2 goes here
already topic 6 immediately played 8 acres in advance
he d2 knight f6
Well, it's clear that there is no fight
there is no question of an opening advantage
but just
White arranges the pieces harmoniously on
somewhere in the center they want to rush e4
but by the way, I myself played this way recently
white and delivered exactly one to one
that's how grischuk play now and that is
then I went e3 fierce two units further
cell 4 spent up to now care for
black so servants of the family basics 7 played
servants to everyone, too, the move is logical, but there is a choice
can rooks 1 and 4 can really
spend temp play e3 queens 2 or 4
so let's see what alexander chooses
you can go and also went to cheat and through
e two and even three then so cover up yes
all fields are there for 4 yes but the difference was in
that my opponent played too much
passive even went c6 some point
and the pawn on e5 did not even put a second
this is for 6 horses 6 once I said I carry
spreading different positions wow yourself here
I am 4 in 1 reception and how do you like this pawn on
7 hangs by the way and 4 like this in
one
one trick is much more effective
I wonder yes because if now
would take away let yourself take you would a dream
and then some action movie starts up
took on e4 took there takes on the same 75 and
don't even take it, it's not even necessary
no need to take it yes you can take it right away
for life in general and he got 4
go right away feeling so so so must
there was an initiative to capture and 4 like
helmets marten 5 horse beats elephant beats
short castling but here are queens 2
and in such cases is it not typical to hit
it should be 5 and then press on this
yaga can try yes right now
let's see how black reacts
I have a fear that somewhere around 18 yet
she d1 toyed while she gives dance toyed
up to 4 until you can’t, then somewhere white
can still accustom to 4 try
suddenly so take it and open everything
the bishop retreats to b2
here apparently until 4 after it went as if at 6
so far too good so far went elephants at 6
but the fundamental question here is whether
as white as acceptable for whites
play e5 and take let's say servants of the scheme
c44 took off like this if what
6 you can already and let's 6d 4 yes then
have here to try to seize the moment
while a little more harmoniously arranged
white pieces but also try to open
really open the center because
let's say it's a long time yes it's a little bit
unfortunate here is the position of the bishop on b2
yes, and now, let's play this role more often
exactly this Grischuk but performs, that is, he
walks-walks e5 wants 4 and like parts
somehow didn’t do it at all, it seems to me the date
or on top of what it does with a point
of course I would like to see the structure
black play d4 but then lose the rush
on b7, that is, Black does not go for it
can bet he would be famous for black 6
bar
yes, that's really right here
it all looked good knights b6
really have to play
it's 4 may already bandaged teacher
that you 4 can but on the other hand
blacks are a little bit stuck here whites
maybe even slower
can play there camp and one to me well
you more often makes no sense to refuse
from pain and by the way he has
additional resources if getting along with 8
you can beat on c5 kuni 4 me something
needs and that's cute yes that is
have taken
took the knight's jump to e4 here too
using here using bundle given
condition 4 we're probably just lifting it
should be 4 4 ​​yes, and there it is torn off on d5
at least it's serious
translate bela i.e. we can beat
need 5 even go bishop b1 then also
detritus
perfectly develops 4 finks of kirov on
maybe here for one to depart with a charge
we will have such batteries there
hope that get along 8 social owners
8 played let's see what's up
until we all moves just exit dc-dc
sun 5 how she has four sashes she has
four here it is not entirely clear what is black
grandfather husband should not clean up the elephant by the way
it is better to give char outdoor but
at least then we will keep points 5
black but if you give char outdoor
can again not hold back because of sleep d4s he
big here then offer nissim
then beat beat give here the moon 4 and
pawn looks like white lost a pawn
retreats to if sona and 7 bishop e7 well
knight c3 eat eat move end 3
there are some yes there don't know in
run jumping on d6
somehow you look very doubtful
yes yes looks very doubtful
black and it seems to me even he looks
somehow tense.
takfir same 4 played hold 4 played yes there
knight f6 threatened as if in 5 queens in 4 now
so that's fine Persians in 4 seconds 6
supports the knight f6 somewhere
get very so inspired will give a
now hovering over black's position j5 but
wow not yet the same elephant 5
sorry elephant same 5 was played combi g5
well, how is this consolidation but now waiting
Fergie 5 finds in if possible
to exchange queens, well, maybe this
still it's still on I don't know lucky for him
By the way, I spied the outcome here instead
words same 5 move end 4 def very
big advantage to black cube c4 like
surprise wow 4pc
and the owner and a bunch of 4 and like this
Alexander Grischuk yawned at this
took advantage of this opportunity 800 she
not shilov concept decided it's understandable yes
such a non-trivial tactic
exactly 4 before after fergie 5 well
thought and thought Sasha exchanged knives 5
and also
in so cd cd50 white has an opportunity
a pawn to win on well us it's nothing
better better there definitely won't be there
you can get worse actually black
can just candy 5 to 3 5 yes here I am
I mean if you take this pawn then
you can only get worse
stability lunar 6 pawn on the same 4 goes
yes, he also hits on d5, meanwhile he hits on t5
eating and playing get along one served to get dressed
2 does not allow but but it's already lights out
released everything to be yes and now
by the way, we were so inspired by it
about grischuk
an advantage to form in fact, but
potentially all the same, here's a pawn diana
some kind of checkpoint yes there are four
by three on the royal they're discounted well
Yes, if Black exchanges even one
a couple of elephant feet on and 4 elephants in 3d cognac
that is, he let the king down in five
can karly than shorter than 60 be queens
one here begins the father we have three
put immediately eat before took took well
this is where the critical moment will be
can they change yes I have 4 lags
brushed away
and up to 4 the lags were swept away, now the pawn will reach
d3 it will be very difficult to try here
this king sneak to e4 then go there
here is our two pawn h 2
that is, we can say that the pawn is 4
just levels three pesh at once
pawn on sorry ariana restrain all three
white pawns
by the way, very interesting different
multi-colored year set in time and in time
pot at e3 well then tomorrow even
ended in time for e3 and the agreement for
a draw follows, well, again we did not guess
with the party of the tour, and it’s even more interesting here
you know while we were watching this game
anand managed to lose to karjakin just
fantastic I don't know what happened there
what is azzam doing she lost here
literally in a minute and a half anand
lost to karyakin let's see what
which one then switch to yours
kilo finished don't feel at you
what a super fast tour
we are left in fact two parties of us
two parties left, let's go where
switch to oni steps or and shakhriyar
mamedyarov and probably by the way yes I am
looked
anand just figure mole anand signal
piece in one move but it's easy
incredibly probable yawns
so here we are on your screens
Anish Giri and Shahriyar Mamedyarov here
stuck minds diorama elephant our all yes
still whites
well, potentially more pleasant yes
if of course you can avoid doubling
2 black frets but something tells
that probably scientists report on 8 8 8
played
mamedyarov here gels somehow somehow
put a rook on the second, yes, here I am
did not know the money one camp is barely there
by the way, rook move 8 is terrible for me
I like it, of course, maybe I should have already
at six as he gives her 5 to go
here already if at 6 black will go white
just and 6 for so look I don't understand
6.6 now won’t finish playing at all
shakhriyar yes it seems to me that but
look at this unfortunate elephant
our topic is what's going on here
the question would be if 8 would move white e6 to
took took rook b 2 of 7
and here is this shah outdoor guide on and
one white win so it looks like something
shakhriyar played a little bit here
got up the date will have to carry the rook on
line with
leave the water to play and 7 and then already
you can go get away funny
opposition e6 e5 and 5 like this we give
pawn and wall up forever this bishop
on our all yes and here somewhere
switching there on line b but by the way we
us 5 may not necessarily be possible
immediately take can be depicted 6 pick up
you can switch to line b immediately here
on level ground like this like this on
Piglet as they say beat received
a large overweight of parquet weights is not
over before but it immediately takes away
immediately went immediately apparently yes that is
true at 5 black will take your pawn
calmly just took it
holds 3 there fit ramage already you can
chess 8 first we will give, that is, the roads are the same
up to shah yet well yes next step i
took it and then threatens to what it looks like
Shahriyar
shakhriyar looks like he will finish the game so rook 8 well
what's f6 we go we don't go we can go
asks f6 of course f6 and then two
the merman, in my opinion, went to give
call back Pozzi Voda 2 on the 8th floor
messenger and 7 looks like just getting along
7 and so I play villains 8 and here is yours
and here you can have 6 of our cells in this
moment i'm 6th not necessarily possible so
do
that went e6 so take here and we
we can give a check and even horses to everyone and the soul
hakone everyone just yes the easiest way
so that not thirsty
or about nothing or any culture of the game dasha
hakone is the easiest for everyone
so what about the tiers
a6 c5 went well wow well that's it
I haven't seen such beauties for a long time pawn on
and this is protected and the ashes of 1 day before the weight is not
played then I don't know she couldn't resist
would play would have seven kinds of informers
protected entrance we will inflict know not
happens every day
elephant same 6 d6 check king life and understandable
which is absolutely won, that is, this
there's nothing to talk about and go to spend
and the gene was 8 and that there the account surrendered yes
some kind of last one with that and with
finally surrenders with two pawns on 7
Mamedyarov
very fast tour I don’t remember this
I don’t remember this, we still have some rains
one batch in nakamura process
still fighting against Levon Aronian
and Lebanon has very little time over there
judging by the electronic board literally there
a few seconds left to give kamorin
nominal extra pawn dou nakamura
an extra but doubled pawn so here is the move
White's move now, by the way, may already
take on f4 here stones actually and
did i.e. take knives 5 took took yes
no, it's changed a little bit more
we release here is such a position yes here
probably we can't
let's keep up with the chess players
I'll try maybe with a big with a big
view from the camera to see what's there
yes yes yes look there
looks like levon pawn now
will spend the same 2
also he does not spend the same 2 went already even
material delusional pawn material
delusional hoja 2 until late 80s takes like
sticky just on the bash with is lost
to feed the leg b spend up took
also collected on b6 since the pawn would
keep him here and maybe some more
wrestle horse 4 later role runs king
running would shoot the steering wheel so I have time
in short, everyone needs well, yes, cow 6
must be turned out will end 525
will put the knight on c5 just everything
cements the end 5 musical
and just it's like like protected
checkpoint hurry shurale five kings step
steering wheel 6 apparently still the horse does not walk yet
loses a lemon and a second pawn so what
defeats hikaru
yes it should rolling king b6 so well
what are you 5 there you can yes you need 55 you can
king skate 80 walker like 4 yes and
coins you don't come out just king it 4
king 4 king bo5 apparently so king d6
ram and now you can king reverse
back back until king and peru and 5 and
king up to 66 came down dasha passed king up to
6-knight d7 was there next move in general
nakamura aronian wins while discarding
lemon a little back
nakamura pull up pull up
nakamura throws back aronian and there
already as planned decent
distance again in the leading group
what changes do we have in if played
logres played in a draw i.e.
between these chess players it remains
before tearing off we have tables we can
see what even we see
look at the table until the gap remains two
points between no this is a mistake to me
it seems in the table in out of the woods then a draw
played by the way, by the way, yes, up to 800, and we have
but this is an error as a result of the shop
correctly take place he has 16 points well
that is, that is, it is purely everything everything
right everything about well everything is right then
there are two points difference between after soy
max your kilo for up to 2 points
everything is still
Aronian lags behind the logri badge 12 s
half a karjakin who wins
ananda then but now karyakin tone pulled himself up
and one and a half nakamura
clean and last sent vichy
ananda giri seven and a half 8 screen
so the gap is kept here between the three
the last yes and the middle of the table so and
holds the gap what can we can we can
maybe try to see some
parties that we did not have time in particular
here is a look at how
trap lost to anand karyakin
looked so fast let's lose
let's see if we have the opportunity
show
show the board let's see the game
anand karjakin i.e. white pieces
Vichy lost literally at the age of 23 there
the worst mistake
it worked out yes, that is, for now it's probably
onlookers of the tournament, that is, some
of the italian party with white pieces well
it would seem impossible to lose
let's try to see let's
let's try to watch anand game
karjakin and so on
italian c3 we all know about this a6
a4 this is now a new trend before
an attempt to immediately grab into space
on the queenside h7 h6 b2 castling
I think this is what we saw in the party
karjakina how spending even it 5
the only grip was perplexed yes how
first you can go a6 and then for some reason
5 apparently if that is if in
the first batch was also at the death of me
something mixed up Dagon repeats it
discharge for the second time allowance times for
at once, that is, apparently such and such
preparation is modern as we said
everything is very specific and so queen b3
so far I really like what he does
everything seems to be logical for White to take bishop e3
took the knight bassem b6
kun t 5 5 it may not even be clear whether it is necessary
before eating why fight a milestone then here
why me why need to be good to 4
and 4 knight d2
so what happened here
he queen f5 before went and developed and then
vichy
of course just miscalculated picked up on
e4 and went to sc2, apparently hoping for
these bundles to win back in the canyon 6
bent over
yes, I’ll note here that the d3 bishop seems to be too
looks good but on f2 all k
sorry till the door hangs on its gonna go
heart 2 knight f6
and the lining of the horse 7 but the lining itself
first we almost have time white
win back pieces well, if that's all that was
before the bishop before 37 mp5 the queen is gone on t8 a4
getting along
8 such a karjakin made a move
strange and in the sphere barely manages
hot hot manages to go to 76 just without
figures by the way it seems to me cracks
record holder for the number of
gifts
celebrated for sergey karyakin them here on
I don't know how he is at such a high level
affects his opponents
really against him very often
such stupid yawns are made and
even in this tournament if we remember
in rapid chess, grischuk dav v
approximately equal position yawned in
one move winter figure yes there is some
fork one of the first rounds of the tournament
rapid chess when he passed won
6 misano even 5 hit by a horse shield hit
under some k did not bring out the plug just like that
but what else do we have kettlebells victory kettlebells
over Babi Yar we actually had time for you
see nakamura outplayed early but
well let's do it again
let's review the game of nakamura aronian yes
for now, for now, time allows us, for now
time lets we can see how
as if the Armenian was one of the main
pursuers and victory that is
defeat is enough for him
painfully hikaru again here came out his
this option is exiled in 4 to e36
the knight went to d2 bishop to 6 then
would beat us more seriously if we
remember before that after the move c5 no
wait hit three
c5 this is what I met in the game
nakamura vs if soup and 4 again
center dream to here its there sunde sunde 7
me here disaster debut played
hikaru queen b3 already turned out to have
worse than pulp and paper 6 they took they took they took b6 here
this is necessary 6 here is this dory's grave and
in fact it was yes it was in the party
nakamura vs forest troops but i think
that somehow the padre mounted an option
ready to trust
general
that's what happened in our party
change in 4 elephant d3 well, this one
structure she too she from different openings
it turns out, that is, White has a double
pawn but at the same time possession potentially
possession of the field by the field e5, finally, also
my grischuk
for 5 for three before and Grischuk played like this
out of your pocket and here's a europe guide in one
from rapid debt
wool b6 but there are some strange
maneuvers filth b6 first b6 attacked there on
Paul here called the same 3 played fables b6
Aronian castling as if this is going
camp alone so far everything is very logical b4
here cb cb lags she c8 seems to be not
blacks must have some serious problems
test here I'm not sure about
go well 8 maybe by the way a friend
it made sense to put the rook, that is, not
it is not clear what prospects login on f8
fritter c8 still defended rook on 8
defended the pawn and now it's time to play
queen 4 well, and somewhere this is already possible
the pawn will hang but you can get along
7 owners of your figure but played with
tempo attacked the elephant, so they took the mp3 and
queen b3 owners 86 for the time being
nothing foretold as they say
there is some kind of game about equality going on
change 4 then this is the way the victim
pawns, I didn’t understand this, maybe not even
I decided to cut not necessarily a pawn
maybe it could just be
roll back to line c yeah show me don't you
enjoy swap queens after
version 3.3 has a motive and then you can
and beat on e5 probably yes, and so
the forecast is closer to equality and here
means that we succeeded donated
pawn exchange owners one he dressed
Aronian is certainly in a strong position on
strong compensation debugging not in 6 hers
b2 some neighbors have started if
get along move we just might need 4
climb up so that's it that's what it could be
firs 22 overlooked when on apparently
just underground first b2 yes here
turns out to take should take and
pawn does not have time to pick up so wait
how can they fail
can he pick up here on p4 it seems
can pick up on b4
but there was probably a queen and systems
starts 8-8 is but maybe
maybe even section 7 skrill is playing
filz systems attacking the f7-pawn and after
queen f8 takes on 7 i.e. the pawn is all
Equally, White has a very passive extra
the queen is most likely in white
just you elements of the problem then
it turns out after the queen d2 some
problems started getting along and one queen c2
skates 4 firs beats d1 but here too
looks like some chance might through
five firs left and so f6 played
knight on f3
back so still do not understand
why can't you take on be four here
apparently it’s not even clear yes it’s clear well in
didn't take a6 queen 4 king h7
well, it's hard to believe that
still win you can do anything
here he played farmer 6 and here
decides to exchange queens from
which, by the way, from the exchange of queens for now
nakamura refuse sc2 f5 played a4
knight c6 in general jumped jumped here
here finally hikaru exchanges
exchanging new chances to win
it's clear that White has a left thanks to
extra pawns here knight c3 knight c6 each
takes a pawn
suits the kings in the center like this
a position arose here, as it were, two ends
4 let's see the moment when
when it finally breaks through, but in this
positions went spinning spinning here
for some reason Aronian decided to play 5
by the way was but she didn't have to maybe he was
they are not an assassin, it is not clear why he was not
must
it seems that okunev alone could help
play law rf 1 apparently king d3 here
this was the glory
bark good martial and the king creeps up
settle down here my wife what what to go
Conor knows how to do your five
took took yes the king and doubled the entrance entrance
manages to do 4 before black achieves nothing
that is, one visible horse had to be
play even 5 exchange king d3 well there and
further similar were the chances here already 4
and f4 this is this I didn't know if the hit parade
retreat is move f4
took took king e2 king in 5 but i
I don't think it's too earthly
obvious idea
and here and here didn't you miss it
aronian because it looks like the knight d2
nowhere because she has 5, that is, such
funny trick he d2 cannot be taken away because
what are we playing 2 she's like this 6
forced line 2 we threaten first
turns to king f2 pick up on f3
and on the same king 2 just located
double whammy takes our 6 turns
completely equally write general played
levon king f4 king and 5 f4 when two
now check on and 7 by the way xanthi
instead instead of king at 5 you can
conde procession what was to play
candy 6 calmly and attack b5 by the way
it may very well be so no that's the feeling
that somewhere here missed somewhere here
did he miss a draw so there is a check on and
eat this we saw even 6 and and that and
not in time not in time it will turn out 2
forced to go to the role in 2 but you know
there is still a version here it couldn't
be a draw
pick up and give check no probably no all
or yes, that is, we destroy the d4-pawn from
do the whites have time for the whites to retreat
have time to take the knight c6 this one
hand on a well-known motive to protect this
a pawn, that's how much it is with aces, yes, very much
for a long time black run back and attack the horse
sim well, then we more or less saw yes
what happened next more or less
saw in general somehow gradually hikaru
won one pawn then the second but also
he succeeded he succeeded
realize well let's get ready
before getting ready for the next tour
see the draw for the next round
we meet there with whom our plays
the leader of the whole forest next round will be
playing with lower weights is interesting
i.e. one of the leaders passed by itself
the main leader is clear yes sole
leader against one is called sidorov
accommodate that try to win
yes, we will finally see this one in the hall
trying to defeat the bark she
going to heaven for someone, that is, like this
derby yes and grandmaster of the united
states of america
shakhriyar mamedyarov vs maxim vash
kilogram karyakin grischuk that is, we have
american couple russian couple russians
will play karjakin with white and
levon aronian vs vichy anand
let's see what we'll even try
by the way, I think maybe
mamedyarov logrov will have the most interesting
may turn up what's interesting is we
somehow while ignoring hair ignoring park
vs the forest we just know by looking at us
watched looked a few times yes well
let's try really let's
maybe we can't be wrong
try to look though here in if
white pieces, but let's do it anyway
Let's see Vasilis with white pieces
vs Anisha maybe just might
he will be able to win develop success to
we remind you that now two points to 1 to 2
the point comes between in with the fox your maximum
kilograms, let's see if
it turns out that in this round they made a mistake if
it will be boring here aula gram logres
wins here then in the next
let's see his pairs or maybe among ourselves
we'll make a bet we can
give we can we are here now until
we will open the season to a hundred hundred vachik according to me
think in what I don't say what in if
will win, well, I believe that this party will
funnier than a party mama geira you
logra to you but of course it is
subjective pretty showing by the way
By the way, I'm sure somewhere on the Internet and
put bets on all these here parties yes
all these matches
I used to remember there was such a marathon site.
troubles probably a moment no marathon troubles
dot com or something like that
some were up need it all the same
our rates are missing a little strange to me
it seems for this there is up to more
suitable sports
well, knight f3 knight f3 good for that
lives who plays he didn't have three
warehouse cleaning is popular with them 35 b3
the same thing as grischuk cases against honeycombs
themselves own self if soy performs
here a little different or stop from
they steps whether he plays knight f6 on sleeping b2
not shy to go the same 6 though
maybe in this case it's true
well that's the whole idea of ​​marketing and so what
there c4 played they will go to the dorn
period real english on same number
seven even three
castling is difficult here goes very fast
game c5 shock white knight c6 knight e5
played and here again, not for a second
without hesitation the horse answers again
By the way, what have modern w what come to
progress has come, and really loiko
what that is because that's if
exchanged and exchanged here
the bishop is nice enough on e5 to
what can even the end of 3d 3 really
so be it I think yes that cavalry three d
and somewhere there is a b1 rook or maybe even without
d3 i just finished in one application
pawn b7 that is why they are the same
decide to save this horse
he will exchange another knight
but by the way, I would venture to guess
nothing a single move of its own yet
like a heart 2 rooms 7 there to take and on d7
taking on life and here you go
one freedom did not take thought
yes, and scored on b7 the pawn can also lead
don't step didn't so wait
skates 7 queen d2 dasha cute
geometry yes take away depart take away
horse well, I'm already 6 years old sara g8
played taken verbatim pc referee means
villages to the couple may turn out yes may
turn out that this is all studied
it may turn out that this is all studied well
that the elephant h3 if the grandfathers threw one hike
it turns out you need to play apparently yes yes it is
diphereline and queen b4 well, we are developing
at the end of 3 if at 34 we have time to pick up and
7 well, by the way, you can, then maybe
some ideas of typology 8 elodea two
collected up took respectfully so no I don't
informed the queen it is clear what to pick up on and
everyone would need to rook here I don't know
reluctantly queen b7 has some whatever
from cover the diagonal essence of the pawn
extra killed
after all, white has an extra pawn a
potential nations again weak somehow
until the king is reached here is a flush
Arrow grandpas one meanwhile played
and he hears walking and this is if
detritus will get 4 and 6 like this
played rush that is up awesome
manages to capture the pawn on d4 in this way, while
here is a horse 3 no longer want at least somehow yes
already looks so awkward natural
horse 3 maybe yes our offers will go again
just this horse will start, as it were
press and so similar if I retreat
on b3 I understand that it doesn't look like
at all
and textured then you need to eat four he
played said freddy 4 it's over
cultural court it's good it's downtown
and including just covered
Frida 4 is not allowed and the horse will come out
humanly what is called will be released 23
I would 8 but still still pawn it
still pawn cavalry 3 now black
Yes, there is some kind of compensation, but
not as significant as I would like
interested in 4 doors 4 instantly well
in my opinion that you even need to beat on 4
flow again it is necessary, well, where 5 apparently beats
yes, and the 4th we have time, yes, this is interesting
that is, on this move we manage to reduce 4
but the truth is right here right here
turn out that black has order, that is
to ordinary cages, some of these
logins and until the end when one pawn
for this activity is some kind of black
just two whole 28 is built by 2 and
this is usually like all this activity
fading takfir d4 wait you can where
more precisely there is more by the way there is
idea fix d4cb cd and then horse p505 but
here beret takes I can eat four cheeses
families 5 there knight c6 finds again
maybe you need to save it, well, the end of the pole
finally, there is this already without haste and
toby rush now up 3 threaten to go up
we want to wag him it is apparently so and
go yes no again go cult again
something in if not heard apparently our
last option middle version yes no
reached the connection yes well jokes jokes but
really the choice was between horse five
icons b5 i.e. played most reliably
but it's really hard to believe
and maybe I made a stupid move
Uncle Vasya may need to play right away
on well immediately go to the circuit play the game
vladivostok pick up both open lines
and immediately aim for doubling by 2
looks like it should be charged
still there cunning cunning he performed before
3 stuck yes where that is offers
white to win the second pawn what a cunning
and then take the blessings
you will have 2 extra pawns, well, it’s clear that
this is weakness and just one after another they
fall by the way there is a story you will drown
I really respect Nisha Geryon from an early age
knew what he wanted
I remember we played one tournament in 2008
young stars of the world in these Kirishi with
Leningrad region and even then he
wooed on zippo hit name
Georgian girl now he is married to
Georgian girl even on another but on
different but apparently already knew that
I wanted to know I knew I wanted so
his fat f5 played well and that's enough
By the way
some witty f3 starts they
players in general I'm here it's me you too
I start to think whether they can somewhere
black for winning a bachata layer ban
took took I still yes there probably
this is probably not a series, I'm single and small
2 maybe there somehow he is with the pace
trying to figure something out here
unfortunately it doesn't go anywhere
comes owners 824 played
it's really a pity to give up this pawn
very one let's play gave here but probably
d1 will have to take something like that
we will have time to raise 3 rooks here
probably already probably okay
will now look at apparently so everything
and going on yes yes yes looked one
went to d1 after capturing rook 3 everything is fine
and played and lada 4
here it is get along vogue a3 lade atrida
a pawn to 3 is still a pity here is a water 4
live fully lag a4 before attacking
well, that is, yes, if 5 whites push the mind and
how hard is gintoki man's grandfather's
I'll change again I don't at again I'll say that
maybe white fights for an hour if we have 7
go here these two central start
some danger poses a genius
output like a chess engine no
responsibility for your assessment
such a thing is not really but begins
like that somehow unwound
that is, here black would think like this
hard draw already
but there is no straight path
so it is not visible so it is not immediately visible
so I immediately feel like
lively 5 black will suffer the same 5 I have
always in 5 somehow trust job
aroused still relaxed too yes
here it seems that the pace is not so
avaya position can everything be allowed here
these are the moves to make but powerful meaning
some one wants something after the same
4 can somewhere prerequisites for
perpetual check and for the fact that white is the king
too settler 3 cooperative
variant cooperative variant means check
water and fadin whites take black walks
same 4 dangle in 2 here they are not he there and
evil from rooks from 2 to regrets even this
cooperative version goes like this
played in if 4 that is apparently we
underestimated the dangerous waters here 5
because if I thought, I thought I played
what did you decide to save for the king
more space again and now
to the concentration camp goes to c7 well, what about a pawn
it's awkward to defend the new kind of youth
there was moisture and somehow you don’t want to where
everyone who is under and 5 to hits and 5
China 6 Dasha now just break through yeah
yes, it seems to me that niches went too far
he started a little too aggressively
some point play in the office he quite
can punish given in if we too
noted that here we have two karjakins there
take advantage of mistakes
opponents and if also not at all
against as they say pick what
lies badly
rook I'm all right again immediately
played and rook 4 then the game is not
get up and can't remember when
yawn one last time after something
so go and 6 can not be stuck here
with the fact that hold the 4th holds the 3 now
you gotta get over gotta go up
naturally so h3 h3 here as in
advertising famous shampoo no chance
dandruff need no checks nothing lodent
up to 4 so well, but here a little bit
I managed here, maybe it was worth the top ones
we did not want to not promise me too
liked that's what about what we
relay at the beginning what can it if near
not so good because he
does not play too sharply, that is, some
need to turn the moment
start kept but still 6
disgusting because where is the camp to go
falls one of the same hangs and 65
is up hanging on clear hanging pawn
for liquids, the most disgusting thing is that blacks have
no, as if perpetual check lowered stroking up to
4 in 4 against 4 yes we take away our chance
scored take away to eat m yes and the king
well, if Jaya runs to the steering wheel our 4 a
if any own cotton can already
And
but it means instead of shahada put it
on too slow given it too and
but owns 5 I will play yes you can and
you can and so for a long time at the most
so tough
so there own d8 is played by anish rook
d8 plays anish so here it is somehow
without prospects sunk grandfathers 7 alla grandfathers
sam sati completes they can't see anything
or they know nothing seen nothing
wants to check or maybe we do nothing
understand no wait on ears true yes
he took a pawn with a check
this move of the rook is all he has yes
not needed
5 king g8 retreats well, now you can
water up to 7 you can now play water
further further I would say that is
the whole idea is to save just about everything everything
loot yes that is I do not give back
pawn q so you need it then depend on it
if Vanish has 10 more seconds in total
stays like this with such a boring
in the end and then it even seemed to us
that black intercepted moisture beat and 7
by the way whitewashing so but this is not the first only
oh, besides, it’s unlikely to release
he probably just takes this rook
the old one on 1 and all the second puts powerful
secrets and well, then the fast and the furious created
hold on em h7 2 knives schemes have ah uh huh
and they just give up just give up
Apparently nothing could be done
what wins in if at least not
its gap from the pursuers is reduced
wrestling karjakina crochet we have there
a couple of draws increases the lead if
because your i lost lost
again anand aronian at the most beautiful
apparently the party we will review it at
us the last batch of the tour remains
karjakin play grischuk omm about her and here
actually 2 nice yes two elephants at the eel
pike against Karjakin's queen but
threatens moze f1 threatens motive one and here
the question is apparently necessary to the bottom in general the question
if forced perpetual check has karjakin
but it looks like he will certainly give fer system
while on interrogation before 7 hearts 6 is
it seemed that the king might be somewhere
nowhere to run run away can't until the heart
7 and just offered a draw to
unfortunately we missed everything here
sharpness yes here I understand that very
the party was interesting to me something very
it was interesting party but again
such a fleeting tour is the last move
let's see what was here and no
here is an action movie that we started from the very beginning
we'll stay from the very beginning and probably res
undermined
let's take a look at
struggle and that's what happened here
Russians it all started like a sice lianka
to the end 3 knight f6 h3
and this is again less often again to the cold
wars are so nasty bustard lessons
nasty bustard and here's the move asema 6
really same 4 plays driving look
chess everyone learns something new
the womb 2 seems to be m and here all the same
can't resist playing until 4000 kanepi
go into a normal civilized
an option to find a raf, but by the way, that one
civilized but in favor of blacks that
there are also options where white is black
already somehow a lot connected, that is, they have
must there candy 7 walk there already white
the same 5 how it happened conditions
plays by the way here the floor is good
alternative 6 in this position until if not
I'm wrong, well, in general terms, let's
quickly skip debut even 5 it
famous 3 before it seems that there is something
mixed up a pawn for everything, however, most
actually e6 cube actually now
reminisce us it's all the transition would take yes
this theoretical position without giving them
barbell but interest is almost the same 5 b5 here
would 5 I'm not sure that is to be such
also exists yes this is grischuk
so confident enough b5
e5 d5 hangs now yes no not really
hangs on e5 in 4 falls on 4 and again
that is, we had a village woman arose to
this is not a french structure yet
from the French defense as if 2
a little strange for
French but by the way yes I think yes
French is easy for blacks
your numbers iria h5 white of course very
doing a lot on the kingside
through b6 his g6 stuck took took
exchange h1 follows and already managed then managed
it is not clear the dacha with black remained there
finished a couple of moves, I won the devil and then
see what happens c4 this is the move
like for blitz yes like this not like that
just c4 go for 4 bishop c4 and spin
2 here are the explanations of the course the explanation goes
4 has vacated field 22 and is fighting for not for
initiative karjakin konev 8 lagina c1
now threatens b3
and it will help to get very tired and very
your dragon looks logical
the knight d7 played strongly the queen d2 before strongly
feasible, but because the letter is
she finished visually beautiful main thing
play blitz beautiful squeeze
g5 yes, it looks like it looks like a mountain
missed Alexander omitted because here
this position is what it is if we match
what is called the material then black
just 2 extra pawns and nothing special
you can’t see the problems already black
cost some ment to the king
take care by the way don't think so well
in general, how did the role come on
here is the case, but then he went somewhere
further then in the park he went on foot to
8 here are some exchanges of queens e-8
king b7 queen b7 king a6
check, but probably some kind of perpetual check
there has been
agency what kind of mines want 6
threatens before first pcm played grischuk and then
departed for 7 but here it is already visible yes it is
I should probably link not because
there was no need to give up a pawn
on and 6 after the heart code 8 he was entitled
had the right to immediately suck and passed
the elephant hangs what is by the way they
yawned him let's scroll can
wait here this back scroll up
moment yes yes that is still scroll well
what is the number of the move say 33 33 the move is the elephant
c4
yes, that's how it is here instead of elephant c4 kuni
5 like her 5 something again
karyakin continues to collect gifts yes
indeed Grischuk won in one move
to not 5, the code is elementarily not 5
gay one time she's very very easy to
anyway it ended
we have a few minutes left to draw
watching the game aronian anand no before
let's take a look at the tournament
let's see what the table is
us there
what we have what kind of alignment ahead
next round seventeen and a half
seventeen and a half points you have woods
17,800 strong and a half at the logra tower
what is it we get
two and a half points in the nose gap Aronian
wins approaching again 3 between him
and 813 for Karyakin 12 for Nakamura 11
alexander grischuk a ten and a half
Mamedyarov
still in last place anand both
and ananda giri suffer another defeat
well, not just not just given
nandu tournament to the oldest up to
the player and it looks like nothing
will change by the way, I won’t be surprised if he
decides to end his career after such
I don't know, I still hope
that Vichy will somehow be able to recover
how many bears brought 40 in my opinion
69 years of birth and 49
Well, in general, it is clear that the oldest
in this tournament
Well, let's quickly see what's there.
vichy happened before let's see what
happened at vichy with ryan yes that is
aronian vs ananda some too
the Italian was played 18 that is
there is no point again
dwell deep on debut
servants 6 slate 2nd here here this
rather strange as for me the idea to go
on same 4 and
pick up on f2 but no wait ka
wait, powerful not quite countries
perch sergey fadeev 2 knight e3 so stop
wasn't it somehow
queens two rings two rook b1 and then how
this is the sharpest yes because it is princely
the frame started is called wait so
tangled and the same tangled
the knight on t2 looks like a pawn for hacking
ready a two b2b 3 wants rook b2
play bishop would one knight b1 fire k
school river no 10 work figure it out
there was war horses 11 too but even horse
d4
OK return Irina 4 cd knight d4
took took so we have here
material we have five and five pawns at
white yes that is a rook and three pawns
against two light curly pieces for black
to be honest must be decent
moved
there should be a primary advantage and then
this is the same magic begins early
which yes we saw in the tournament
games when these figures lay down and suddenly
develop something like this such a web
weave develop very dangerous
stock exchange activity 3 clear how how
you know again the sayings in the park with
the weak do not change keeps well on the very
it's all jokes again
I realized that white is such a real hope
white in this position is the outline of the game
against the king before it is understood that in the endgame
I don't want to go with dignity 35 more
everything seems to be ok, you have to try
open lines for fritters
horse in 3d and elephant hd and apparently decisive
mistake I should have gone at 6
it seems that it helped yes yes canisters and that's all
we are in 6 of 7 and 6 yes a little limiting
and a horse and on a move like 6 will now be
opportunity over everything just go with
protect a pawn on the seventh rank with vegetables
let's say with the move feride 7 and black
full order yes it looks a little like this
move but under yourself and hall bern and because
it admits the following pretty
cute attack like 66 is the only one
horse on same 5 now rebound
pawn and all after iv 5d and follows well and
get white that's all all white
figures
gathered on the kingside and
get to the black king before 4
an attempt, as I understand it, to somehow open
some lines outline the game to arrange
but not to keep up well, there's still levon in
in his characteristic elegant manner
when already till when already party decided then
there is a finishing move such a beautiful rook beat
f5 I understand not to accept the sacrifice
doesn't help either, because
somewhere in the camp everyone comes on the same horse
hits h7 i.e. like fireworks like this before
everyone understands checkmate in 1 move king and
everyone has to walk
check from here shox f6 chance d4 that is so
step by step yes you remind me of this
classic batch of 100 units will take a look
parallel yes where are the steps on the seventh
row i sweat i sweat stale mate at the end
tones king on why the elephant and in 4 king
c6 heart 4 check but also what of this king
the unfortunate is driven, that is, this
you understand that the king is up to 7 series d5
follows up
weighing 5 could just be the same elephant 5
such a beautiful mat in the center of the board well
inspirational attack levon aronian from what
say yes, I think it's very cute
but things are true too so much higher
of course helped what to say yes well
I don't
Shengel we have already looked yes there is something
strange thing happened what else do we have
there were but no more effective games
there were yes and some in each
own everywhere there were some rooks
nicki cow us at kama rai party
we probably won't review it, but
I can say that we finished in the position where
each with water and a king
please total exchange of all
forces in the thirty-fifth leaving
total exchange of everything
worked out
catalina is already here, yes, but you know
that's interesting so this is such a joke again
but about the so-called in my opinion
sophian rule it was called
initially when there was a ban on
agreement before
for a draw prohibition for an agreement for a draw
up to 40 x yes, that is, I am from different tournaments
in different ways somewhere up to 30 is impossible
chess player agree nothing here
somewhere up to 40, but here we are 35 moves
left on the water, that is, theoretically, I
up to 40 moves
I can have time to exchange all the pieces
had them five more moves king life so
wait we approach bella become
it doesn't matter, so I played h1 lags on the king and
everyone will play water ev1 took yes it is
move number 38 agree dedicate
the rules for a draw still cannot be, but to play
no longer but then maybe attacks by 2 0
get this position [ __ ] will agree
let's get ready for the next one
tour gradually let's start preparing for
next round let's see what we have there
waiting on the way for more than half of the desk
today played yes it will be round 6 on
today and
from nine to tour 6 for today but and if
we recall that we have a common
offset yes, that is, it is already 15 on the account 15
party yes here in this tournament
and tomorrow, as I understand it, they will repeat
today's schedule but reversed
color by the way its so I think they are the same
how much is played, that is, 18 and 920 san
party among themselves
yes yes there for three days each other rest and
then again all the same not the same people play
in twenty-seven parties among themselves but
there will appear new new potential
client vladimir kramnik will replace they steps
it seems to me that such a client is at home with him
customers here are interested, yes, because
that on the feet ugi does the game clearly not
it worked out, but from Kramnik you can do something
to be expected, including
place on the podium and even victory in
tournament and so the sixth round we are similar
waiting for grischuk aronian and there's nothing for me
confused in this we are considering
look and garanyan nakamura nand yes
here we have someone who plays anandom before
Grischuk vs. Aronian Anish Giri vs.
sergey karyakin archive logs and tools
but this is what we're going to watch
I'll see the second place against 1 to the leader
against the nearest pursuer and
fabiano caruana fight shahriyar
by the way, mamedyarov turned them around the game
I'm already desperate to win something like
there two and a half points dug up and
lose for sure defeat will already
sad sad yes that is in if bye
well, show me less actually scored
points than the closest pursuers before
zero today that is no need to cry and
did not agree the gap was reduced to
sticks dwindled at such a rate
by the way, if everyone again requires tours
half a point they trudge will not catch up with him
until it's gone it won't turn up until I remind you
that last year everything is also very
luckily folded up for you woods in
Rapid, yes, but then he overtook him in blitz
Magnus ends who is there like a locomotive
swept and scored just nailed to that
an incredible amount of points so far we have
leader if we separate up to 1 tournament
another the leader of the blitz we have similar
maxim your kilogram well, yes, most likely
it looks like we have the maximum of your logs
the leader of the blitz shows us now
habit concentrating Vasya at the board
Alexandra goryachka there I wonder what
water one by one from a couple sits
By the way, I always wonder what they have
going on in this tournament they know everything
here they are probably enough presidents
relaxed yes probably enough
relaxed but because all the same yes blitz
and quickly and yes, that is, I understand
the players, as it were, might make me uncomfortable with
autumn currency
uncomfortable and then, as it were, reaching out to
pawns there for 2 if black playing in
suit but here they are always elegant
dressed in a suit
Karyakin as far as I can see yes but in general
loggers somehow put ice in jeans
there is chess this sport
dispute over what is
chess art sport science oh well
that is your ate graph of such an athlete
represents most likely yes that is not
each one represents a different area
yes, that is, here it is, here it is, some
I don’t know such artists, but here they are
sergey
in costumes, by the way, even the building itself
there they play a pencil from this and
Pacino is such a beautiful building
the building is somehow even low uncomfortable
lead just in some sports
costume, that is, we criticize a little
here screams let's let's confess
that we are a little screaming very so softly
but we hope you give it criticism
constructive criticism
easy to change easy to change
change so your again come on with against
if sleep well because of this party we will
we have a couple more to watch
minutes before the start it seems that everything is already
all the players took their places
say yes very so perky before
a blitz tournament
strangely enough, everything goes by so fast
oddly enough there are no more draws here it is here
unexpectedly, that is, the effectiveness in
rapid exceeds performance in
blitz and colossal and then
we'll try there as close to the end of the day
bring some statistics yes well there
performance, but this is probably related
with the fact that everything was wrapped up like this
not typical I was there too much
too many were successful
parquet four games out of five in the round
ended with dies that is three
minimum on the worst bad tour in
this plan it's type yeah it's two accidents
victory, but here, by the way, I think it is
also depends on
technicians, that is, they have less time for
realizing the advantage of a and somewhere can
be the release they release just even
Grischuk and in what an amazing way
previous soar while against measles
accompanied Karyakin of course there are two
extra pawns we improve positions simply
than one move you and gradations
surprise unbelievable of course I would be
there would be control 25 let 10 before this
just not just not an arbitrariness for
Grischuk, no matter how old he is
time, as far as I understand, does not matter
how much time to give him at the beginning yes
it is clear that he will be there from the 30th move
play for a minute
but here is the question in adding to in
classics then 30 seconds in fast is 10
seconds and he has time, but already on 3
seconds need a little start
nervous btw hypothetical question
how much money do you need to invest grischuk o
so that it never reaches will become this
did not reach one minute
Well I don't know if this is true or not
whether he is your e against you forests here we are
we start like this, but what do we have symmetrical
naked symmetrically this c4 was taken by horses
the answer is that this is the whole option in
which we have already seen low draws but
even I don't play black like that
this 69 bay windows even I already have a theory here
learned it workout castling dc-3
so we can be maximizing some new
life will breathe into this position or what or
so we'll see a repeat that's who's already at
they played us like that already more expensive against
white thoughts of the enemy himself and the city again
well, here it’s like 4k, well, here it is
maybe some kind of
semi news yes there played from the moon 3 in
I remember exactly this position Kramnik played with
moon 3 all killed pretty fast there
when trying to play knight d4 but also there
everything has already been studied to a draw, here is the maxim
trying something else so new to us
at least a new move well enough
it is logical that white is nothing here
gets no day from black
weaknesses illegal 4 goes what's there
kanye 405 is a slightly different variation but
principle 1st floor
again, but sorry, but what is this
they took they took they took the queen queens
put the knight on d6 and also something
similar probably probably more successful
reaction to not worth editing is not worth it
black is already quite relaxed yes
Well, there's no time to relax
against these guys it's true yes it's there
can take to the most boring
position and here left the queens thoughts
left the queens immediately puts the knight on d6 in
this is something new, yes, as I understand it, well
unexpectedly a little yes so what are we here
will be white probably black queen the
first and 4 I thought the choice between ferris d2
there somewhere aiming at 6 or firs up
4 well then the queen sang he went through
three-four for 5 black should jump
it's not the living conditions playing here that
white is somehow a little easier all the same
play yes here this option one here
make an unobvious move or but apparently
he just protects the book but she does not
wants to give
greed has triumphed yes that is
owns on t1 well, queen 4 that's all
probably queen 5 is necessary somehow ladisa
and so does forza 5 play well 5
here some move there are 5 owners
probably retreat to b6 yes somehow maybe
be 4 but though or it's too much
sweeping well so here are these think over and
too smear black even 5 to
it is not clear what whites are attacking here, but
it does feel a bit white
are more active and where is it the most
somewhere to attack so there is a funny
very tactical idea now i
discovered scrapped bassem knight c6
judges obscene 75 but unfortunately she doesn't
passes the saffron and behind the heart 7 and because
fergie 5 motive is at least like this
there is a know about logger played by candy
three fold river view symmetrically
the horses are already on the trumpet blowing
lights out and on d 8 well, that is, here it is again
some before sending now mine we can
give there to the guile of ulf anderson yes
that is, all the same, in protection technology
increased
defense technique
the price is colossal yes since those times well
play queens change no no but
then the horse jumps to them
horse in 4 by the way make some sense
by the way, this happens promisingly
the spirit of the action just wants to eat on e6
exchange bishop spoil spoil
hairstyle what is called she an elephant u
say elephant c8 move fire perhaps not
the smartest yes, then the cult again already
we’ll put you in, yes, and they get along there too
systems somewhere behind we will go
and that somehow but something that's the countries that
you need two pebbles and it's annoying, yes it can
a little annoying
hand if you glass is not included in the background
she apparently he horse somewhere maybe need 4
even she protect
ale ale or maybe he's so lucky he will drive away and
somehow sun 8 i'm trying to figure out how far
queen we are on c 15 3 that is, some here
there are margins maybe in the center yes somehow
this is the ending
did they take yes on the computer 4 apparently unsuccessful
for e3 we need to retreat by a number
same and sent him the queen e3 pawn b7 to
protect but even here I don't know maybe
maybe white piping and 5 maybe why not
immediately get along everyone dined at melodyne
all nice gave grandfather all nice
by the way, here it gets loggers for something
before this was generally considered won
yes it was a big advantage will be so
heart 3 well thought in if and maybe
be like an alternative kite queen b6
considered he gets along burdock all the same
has changed, but now he organizes actively
counterplay went dressed d2 true lets
beat on e6 is it good for white
maybe he has enough counterplay there
2 more there, you connect the node of Odessa 8 with
they have every e3 date that's just it
when they are already stuffing 2
defeat is important and even kun is up to 6
probably go here and sit by the pool
defended on f2 attacked and there were two
season if vasilisa starts now on
escape with such success makes me look like you
slice of such positions to beat well
bad luck close to him impossible
just not by the way, I wonder how they are
such a defense technique is trained
maybe
I suspect it's just asking for a lot
such similar positions against fighting
against the engines they play b7 rook b2 here
the development of events now takes us to e6
f.u.
and can take her on and 6 at all
optionally it was by the way and what of the womb
6 and here is the service
nd4 well, it’s not clear what is here
next do korolev reading oh you a
here is the king fadin there is only one queen
there is but the truth is she is three not to go and 3 yet
no new function is obtained by creating d1
something like this try a little
strain, that is, again strategically
yes, that's what they call static
White has an advantage of the bishop over the knight and
better peshich on i structure but for now
it is not clear how Bella and now they are spinning
how white will improve the interaction of figures
but we see on and honestly say that it is possible
again we made a mistake with the choice of the party yes well
like this
our leader plays very calmly very
trying to take as little risk as possible
and against him the loggers did not enter much
risks not much risks alexander
grischuk
let's try to switch to alexander
Grischuk and if we have such
possibility yes if we have one
the camera feature there is very interesting
comfort let's take a look there there
just an incredible position now on
board in my opinion in my opinion grischuk just
look at the last move of the rook 8 1 and 8
and 6 play play levon aronian is wife
so white you communicate just with a song
beautiful bad it's very different
beautiful move before that look
please before that yes before that on and
6 lux, by the way, he could not be taken
just caught the white queen and here
positionally it looks like
it seems that grischuk is making a shed for us
the most that he did not do with himself
mamedyarov give white fields total
domain
promotion rings 4 well here you are please
the rook crawls on 6 to 16 26 don't remember
when was the last time oranges at 5 so
caught
exactly rook hold a6 so korolev one
played grischuk but what is there where the rook is
does it lead us to the same smartphone 6 pasha
tilt 6 offers caught like a 6
owned
that is, he gave the queen to hope for the soul
so grischuk took f4 now
fun up taken away and that planet on d1
oh i have a suspicion
queen 4 so behind the four key a
now for 4 in my beat it is necessary 6 to
beat 96 grischuk
you're still unclear can't i'm not sure
that somehow already f3 is impossible in2 and in3 or
konig barely horse f3
he will help in three shoves at once and black f3
let's go but fat grant f3 and oh well
took yes I 3 not sure what gave dressed
3 king barely I put mastering 86
vladi f8 and if the king barely me isla de
f3 probably and by the way not having mastered the arrow
keep the souls of this data that's interesting
so that we show this option which we
discussing everything grew bloody byd f3 like
will be cute on the king in 3 mana same 4
well, there is an intermediate step
projet step the same one ogr still someone else's
like this, you see, these 3 did not give
wench 7 immediately king or two all
tricks see alexander
and I beat h2 here too beat h2 so well
Now here you need to understand whether they can
white pick up on her 6 because we
it seems like you can defend yourself by bringing it up to 3
everything is safe here, but then a pawn will run
even gradually and most likely black
win I would take this pawn for a walk so
walk owning 6 before still already on steam
which, that is, is not necessary here
By the way, because in Fiji 2 and a gathering
she has five, keep yours, but she has 5
why are they 5 to defended the pawn took
foot also posed a threat to two more hike
it’s unpleasant that we say you can’t take an elephant
so there that there took on and 6 sasha me
something already white was better taken on e6 like this
queen h3 plays aronian and now maybe
create or even 3x
step the same step with the same and 6 again the same 6 it
holds and
also the 6th keeps 3 so we go so
apparently what are you
very creative game without queen king
h7 la holds 3
but by the way, let us remind the audience that earlier he
already won without queen similar position
vs. nakamura so looking in front of the same in
party from Karjakin, that's which
ended in a draw can not also queen in
the final position was missing, that is
win trailer just let's queen
up to from excellent queen h2 on yet
Grischuk didn't win, let's not
jump ahead queen h2 so now
st clothing problems 3 starts like
you have to double it because
otherwise number 45 before such a consolidating
that he doesn't want to play like me not all
still your camp while alexander showing
two landys are here an interesting moment now
scheduled h4 la keeps 4 not turned off
queen h2 by the way did not turn off queen h2
here already now aide some motives here
these horses will jump there on t5 t6 where
also checkmate on the horizon there so so so
the one was playing the radio alone in zone 4
yes, the question is who will get there first
the opponent's king is there and the bishop is the same 3
outlines the same water 2 where he went through h10
and he doesn't seem to mind a draw
up toe md5 gets candy 5
watts no no then the account further what
elephant 3 but I understand that it's simple
hits twice what just hits twice this
on e3 they put b3 stability here
unbelievable give me two horses is it possible
they don't go to kuni trip like that
already three wait serves whether the necklace is serving
3 to the end of 43 just played dial up
by the way they end years owning the same 8
plays like how you hold 8 like a southpaw
knight f6 what is their knight f6
interrogation yawned hurt the earth den
he's incredible and something happened
unbelievable happened just just doom
on the nerves for seconds he had
there three four seconds before and
attack interesting interesting discussion well
as we see till the party ends
really this is how it is
they say such a party is valid for
fans, that is, the assessment changed there
I'm sure several times back and forth
Alexander Grischuk wins, well, just from
start to finish incredibly interesting
party I think maybe the end of the day we
let's get back to it while it looks like
really party not only that wound and
just like that and then kettlebell kettlebell continues
play it like the only party
which is still
which is still in the process of karyakin well
trying another safe up to execute for
execute another safe to what
specially just fall which positions
to demonstrate
I'll get up to demonstrate my technique
defense technique for so actually already
here the king has already changed to f4
here is the same position, after all, he jumped
king on f4 yes just done series
from several moves
the king goes to e4 looks like a king
came to e4
I don’t know I don’t understand yet how how to punch
yes, now we have a king on
egg water on d2 is hidden
or maybe some bunch of heat from there
10 to 25 threatens no hi5 bark g7 yes here
the same 5 he played just the king of the same shooting
rudder e3 rook d5 and that and do not break through to
refrigerator it would be a draw then here
here the bishop is added for white, the bishop is added for
black horse before me is something hardly
does it replace something yes it looks like
holds here important important this
a lot of really good advice
we give this advice really sensible
a rook behind a passed pawn this is
really important rook behind
passed pawn this is a reliable recipe
cody is there somewhere in time to still
and the bottom lost but still 3
second will not lose so karyakin
unwavering hand water to 2 to 6 water
up to 2 to 6 all all the same lada 4 shah
so sometimes
just a reward for the mountain away from
walks gives chance up to 4 so here's the king on
same 3 gone its quite quite right
maybe because it just keeps yes i
I don't know if it was again
whether lost by sergei karyakin no longer
once or twice he is so what is worse there
draw demands or what demands is not alien
or three times yes and it seems just just
agreed so let's take a look there
I hope not all the same not with time
there ain't no nothing like a draw
yes, and so a draw for Karyakin's weights a draw for
pockets with mamedyarov respect them a draw
kilograms of your tears, which is not surprising
yes, we started watching
this course party lair and weight face
it turned out that the cat had gas for him
noir
and we are very competent and that switch
for the game of grischuk and the saran she is right there
already there was just anything and one more
a couple which we for some reason forget
say won vichy anand anand won
black o nakamura you can see what
there happened let's quickly
little review here's what happened
nakamura with anand and probably with us
here's the schedule for our after each
three rounds we take a short break
until here we let's instantly literally
let's take a look at what's there one on the
snack amurai was I'll start with some
entry positions there from 11, as I understand it
same variant same variant with me
hikaru played who he played saran a
Yes, well, in general, we went, went, while everyone
only somehow Vichy managed
exchange blackfield that bill disgraced
bishops, which is perhaps in favor of black
of course, yes, with a horse on and 4, they took
took that call on Ezio but how is it
can dc seriously no this is incredible
that is, dc and calcium one is some kind of and
border end 1 and I understand that here
on swords, I probably planned Hikaru this
and maybe forgot just swiping b3 then
there can not even beat the presence of a powerful
or give three at once, but for queens 4
can be immediately taken on the hip
cerebral palsy for this was played clearly what it is
terrible positional move that was
played a tactical idea to the end one
ferz system here got the vichy edge
and it seems that I already want 4 I missed it
to such a one on f 24 they still accelerated and
now take she b3 another pawn diablo 3
heart 5 was taken and taken, and here it’s not already
stop in a similar vein he way yes
I think I've already won
tournament
c4, that is, this is his second time
mounted 400 and cd by don fabio knife
head played turned on the same took away
whether an extra piece or a knight on 4
backache yes yes yes yes here I would be the same 6
extra conda vs american
grandmaster this is not the first time we
we see furby d5 e5 played and rook d2
here again the cavalry is threatening
up to the time of the knight on c5 mass d1 follows
well let's break it down
take a short break, leave and come back
in just a few minutes three rounds
we have three more rounds ahead
stay in from the woods stay with us until
will start in ten minutes
round number seven we still have the seventh eighth
ninth round play the position of leaders
while the same but the tables I thought
talk before start before start
next round
secret own field place and simple
captcha moment sufi miracle world space
fighter in circles
cycles now club stella brain stand and
cast on the truth mitsubishi i want me
single thing you from stock
[music]
sea ​​meter read
we break out of pinky
from brush sands even
ball
and his life on the line
[music]
explay txt
he was in 7th grade
art florida do the while the sale of
time mine yell experience
[music]
but
Well, dear friends, let's go back to
our studio here in st louis
we return to the town hall of the city of lebanon where
continues till the tournament continues
the last three blitz rounds left on
today and here it will be useful to remind
that tomorrow on the decisive day do not forget
chess game starts two hours earlier
action that is it will be
early-early morning we will have it here
12 o'clock it will be noon to
central european time so
we will now watch round 7
I think we'll keep watching
a party of leaders from the forest, but what if
again we miss you then we'll go
somewhere let's do it again
quickly
look at the table what is happening there
in the lead still came out soda let's
here we have a table leading up to
Vasilisa is still seventeen and a half
Levon Aronian has 14 kilograms for Maxim
15 till here's the triplet hasn't changed
in fact lotus k will save two s
half off your maxim
kilogram saves you full points
takeoff keep weight face on fourth
still karyakin nakamura loses
Grischuk is chasing him
but this is actually all the changes, yes, in
top there half table 12
but somehow we already define how
who will fight for the first three places
I can say with great certainty
that u from the forest maxim started the game in lebanon
aronian sergey karyakin will be in
the prize three from this, yes, it looks like
what are these guys who are on
pedestal breakfast of these four before
three of them and so three yea two me
almost as a guarantee to give that two of this
shooting tomorrow move up on a pedestal
for third place yes probably not yet
lost the chance to wrestle and hikaru
nakamura with alexander treat com anish
weights and
vishi anand share the last so and so
started very quickly yes very quickly
flashed hands the game started in if
collect and fabiano caruana so what else
one
synthesis another greenfeld that face 40
that dc is not all the same c6
Fabian after all c6 it's funny to talk here
but this is perhaps more pain in combat
option with what dc caucasus is strange
by the way, no matter how strange it may seem
406 played not batteries and b3 well, at least
at least it's already encouraging it's already it's not
full symmetry and took up the name
took took c5 here here anything
scrapping can happen b2 this is also something
long long theory 2cd office kun do
4-6 cd took to 4-6 but here somehow
fierce 11 played yes and played hearts
one played and
Fabiana Slates 807 Well Pretty Fast
will give a second 2 white must walk and
somehow the knight on b3 goes some c5
Held somehow finish the invincible
hold the thread put the stove on c5 there
rook on b1, that is, an attempt to put pressure on b7
when 2 game and so go when 2
play here knight c6 yes and but and by the way
some micro problems for black
still remain surrender yes well not so
that at once everything is already level db-3 here
here, as it were, there is a desire not to
exchange on d4, yes, white has two knights
claim for 1 share, too, field on field
to 4 so black plays get along 8
for now let's say that the capture on c6 is taken
with an elephant to exchange the white field that
of course, seriously facilitate the task so
rook d1 mind played then rearranged
radii one per t1 is quite understandable
and the solution is possible and in up to 8 like black yes
by the way, black is not needed here
had problems
18 fd8
whites play something you drink at the end maybe
turn out to be a weakness so so so what
somehow not very sure.
in one right here I would be serious
considered trying to run away from the exchange
horses, but somehow marten 5 is impossible
play until choke 5 set
queen on 6 is quite possible to me
ass elephant ev1 some yes maybe
there is fierce but there we are at 4 there is a clearing
you can use by the way you can somewhere and
ringing and 5 check this rook on b1 them
doesn't she want to go back there but here
I don't like at least one 137 played
heart 7 played by caruana retreating real
in theory, as it were, c5 needs wounds in the heart
synta too this this added one more
striker here on a pawn with a color somewhere
in if c5 beeline entertained corny
you can lose naked if c5 then what
then the elephant did not understand
goes to if it looks like yes that is it
wants somewhere
sun 3 move such well, to put it mildly
weird but if and if even beat
want big destiny 660 so emphasized
securely fabiana acts covered up there
the square again the squares c5 the knight on b3 a little bit
clipped me sure bug unhook you
you know it starts to take shape
scientist wants u black now just
note that age will be better